OUR. WE'RE GONNA START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. SENATE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY WILL COME TO ORDER
THE MORNING AS WE CONTINUE TO
TAKE SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN WRIST
THE SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME
THE PUBLIC TO OUR HEARINGS IS
PROVIDE ACCESS TO BOTH IN PERSON
AND TELECONFERENCE DISSIPATION
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO SPEND TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON A COMMITTEE WEBSITE
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
OUR ANNOUNCES NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR ZERO.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO MORE X.
PLEASE REFER THE SENATE IN
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WEBSITES I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
HERE IN THE- STREET BUILDING I
ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
COME TO ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED SO
WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR CORPSMAN
BEGIN THE HEARING WE ARE JUST
SIMPLY LACKING ONE MEMBER. TO
FORM A QUORUM- BEFORE WE HEAR
TODAY'S PRESENTATION- AS SOON AS
ONE MORE MEMBER ARISE WE'RE
GONNA STABILISED A QUORUM- ALL
RIGHT. WE HAVE ONLY ONE ITEM ON
TODAY'S AGENDA THAT'S S. B.
EIGHT SIX SIX BY SENATOR WIENER.
WHO IS PRESENT. SO LET ME JUST
ANNOUNCED THE PROCEDURE WHICH IS
DIFFERENT THAN ART- TYPICAL
PROCEDURE. SO ON EACH SIDE EACH
SIDE WILL BE AFFORDED THE SAME
AMOUNT OF TIME THE BEFORE
PRIMARY SUPPORT WITNESSES WHICH
WILL BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR A
TOTAL OF TWENTY MINUTES. THE
BEFORE PRIMARY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WHICH SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR A TOTAL OF.
TWENTY MINUTES AT THE TOP I'LL
GIVE UP I WILL ANNOUNCE EVERY
FIVE MINUTES AND- WILL ASK.
THOSE WHO WISH TO PARTICIPATE-
TO WRAP IT UP AFTER TWENTY
MINUTES- THEN WILL LINE UP THOSE
WHO ARE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND I SEE SEVERAL FOLKS HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM- TO GIVE IN
PERSON TESTIMONY. BOB YOU
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHETHER YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AND
WHEN YOU APPROACH THE MIKE FRONT
DOES SIMPLY STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL LET
ME REPEAT THAT- JUST SIMPLY
ANNOUNCE YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION WHETHER YOU SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE THE BILL I NOTICED A
QUORUM- MADAM CHIEF COUNSEL IF
YOU WOULD. CALL THE ROLL FOR
PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM. FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM UMBERG
HERE AMBERG HERE FOR JESS.
PORTIS PRESENT ZERO THE RUSSELL
YEAH IT DOES SO HERE GONZALEZ
HERTZBERG JONES. JONES HERE
LAYARD HERE WHERE'D HERE STERN.
WHAT COUNTS HERE WHAT KASKY HERE
WIENER AS A WINNER PRESENT YOU
HAVE SEVEN HERE ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A QUORUM- SO BACK TO WHAT I
WAS SAYING A MOMENT AGO SO THE
SPORT OPPOSITION WILL LINE UP-
IRRESPECTIVE OF YOUR POSITION IN
LINE UP WITH MY PHONE JUST GIVE
US YOUR NAME AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. BOB THE
STEPS TO GET HERTZBERG FOR- YEAH. ALSO ONE OTHER MATTER OF FOR
PURPOSES OF TODAY'S HEARING
TODAY'S HEARING ONLY CENTER
HERTZBERG- HE WILL BE REPLACED
JUST FOR TODAY'S HEARING BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE- ANYONE WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE WILL BE REMOVED FROM
THE HEARING ROOM F. TO HEAR THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CORE
PRESIDENT WILL THEN GO TO THE
PHONE LINES THOSE OF THE PHONE
LINES IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE
WILL GET A TOTAL OF SEVENTY FIVE
MINUTES TO SPEAK. WITH THOSE ON
THE PHONE LINES WILL GIVE THEIR
NAMES AFFILIATION IN THE
POSITION ON THE MEASURE THOSE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE
WILL BE GIVEN AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME SEVENTY FIVE MINUTES TO
SPEAK AND THEY WILL JUST GIVE US
THEIR NAME THEIR AFFILIATION IN
THE POSITION THE MEASURE. ALL
RIGHT. UP TO SEVENTY FIVE
MINUTES CORRECT. YES YES YES DO
NOT REQUIRED TO GO SEVENTY FIVE
MINUTES THAT'S CORRECT. ALL
RIGHT- SO LET US LET US GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN. WITH US SENATOR
WIENER CENTER WINNER OF THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES I WANT TO THANK THE-
CHAIR THE COMMITTEE STAFF- FOR
THE STRONG ANALYSIS- ON THE
BILL. OUR COLLEAGUES TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SENATE BILL EIGHT
SIXTY SIX- WHICH WILL- EMPOWER-
TEENAGERS TO PROTECT THEIR OWN
HEALTH- BY GETTING VACCINATED.
SPECIFICALLY IT WILL ALLOW-
PEOPLE ABOUT TWELVE YEARS AND
OLDER- TO CONSENT TO
VACCINATION. WHEN THE VACCINE
WAS APPROVED BY THE U. S. FOOD
AND DRUG ADMINISTRATION AND WHEN
THE VACCINE MEETS THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ON IMMUNIZATION
PRACTICES OF THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION.
SB SIX SEX IS NOT A
REVOLUTIONARY IDEA IT BUILDS ON
LONGSTANDING EXISTING.
CALIFORNIA LAW ABOUT THE AGE OF
CONSENT FOR RECEIVING HEALTH
CARE. RIGHT NOW- THOSE TWELVE
AND OLDER. CURRENTLY UNDER
CURRENT LAW HAVE THE AUTONOMY TO
MAKE CRITICAL DECISIONS ABOUT
THEIR OWN BODIES AND THEIR OWN
HEALTH CARE UNDER SPECIFIC
CIRCUMSTANCES. RIGHT NOW A
TWELVE YEAR OLD TO OPEN UP- CAN
CONSENT. TO RECEIVE THE HPV
VACCINE. AS WELL AS A HEPATITIS
B. VACCINE WITHOUT THEIR PARENTS
CAN. RIGHT NOW. FIVE PEOPLE
TWELVE AND OLDER CAN CONSENT TO
MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT
FOR SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
INFECTIONS FOR DRUG AND ALCOHOL
RELATED DISORDERS FOR INJURIES
RELATING TO SEXUAL ASSAULTS OR
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE AND
FOR MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS. BOB
MINORS OF ANY AGE CAN CONSENT TO
ACCESSING BIRTH CONTROL AND
ABORTION- YET TEENS UNDER
EIGHTEEN CANNOT CONSENT TO OTHER
VACCINES. WHETHER IT'S THE FLU
SHOT THE CODE BAXEEN FOR THE
MUSICALS- MAXIMUM. EVEN IF A
TEENAGER DESPERATELY WANTS A
VACCINE AND NEEDS A VACCINE FOR
EXAMPLE IF THAT TEENAGERS AT
HIGH RISK OF SEVERE DISEASE
WITHOUT VACCINATION- I EVEN IF
IT'S NOT BEING VACCINATED
PREVENTS THE TEAM. FROM PLAYING
SPORTS OR BEING IN BANDS FOR
HAVING A JOB THAT THEY'RE
PASSIONATE ABOUT OR BEING ABLE
TO GO OVER THEIR BEST FRIEND'S
HOME. THEY STILL CANNOT BE
VACCINATED UNLESS THEIR PARENT
CONSENTS. BY CONTRAST ON VARIOUS
STATE TO ALLOW TEENAGERS TO GET
VACCINATED ON THEIR OWN WITHOUT
PARENTAL CONSENT. FOR EXAMPLE IN
RHODE ISLAND'S IN SOUTH CAROLINA
IN OREGON AND ALABAMA AND
WASHINGTON DC. IN THE CITY OF
AGE OF CONSENT IS ELEVEN.
DESPITE INCREDIBLE ADVANCES IN
MEDICAL TREATMENTS AND VACCINES-
DEADLY DISEASES PREVENTABLE
DISEASES LIKE MEASLES WHICH WERE
ONE TIME CONSIDERED ELIMINATED
IN THE U. S. CONTINUE TO BE
REINTRODUCED IN CALIFORNIA. THIS
IS LARGELY DUE TO RISING VACCINE
HESITANCY AND MISINFORMATION.
MEASLES FOR EXAMPLE SPREADS
EFFICIENTLY AMONG BACKS ON
VACCINATED USED INCLUDING THOSE
WHOSE PARENTS HAVE CHOSEN TO
BLOCK THEM FROM RECEIVING THIS
POTENTIALLY LIFESAVING VACCINE.
BAXEEN MISINFORMATION HESITANCY
HAS ALSO LED TO TRAGIC OUTCOMES
DURING THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. BUT EVEN IN SITUATIONS
WHERE PARENTS DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THEIR KIDS GETTING
VACCINATED IS AND THIS GOAL IS
NOT JUST ABOUT THE SITUATION
WHERE A PARENT. IS AGAINST
VACCINES ARE REFUSING WE KNOW
THAT UNFORTUNATELY MEDICAL
NEGLECT OF CHILDREN IS REAL
THERE ARE FAR TOO MANY FAMILIES
WHERE THE PARENTS ARE SIMPLY
NEGLECTING THE MEDICAL CARE OF
THEIR CHILD THEY'RE NOT AGAINST
VACCINES ARE JUST NEGLECTING
WAR. SITUATIONS WHERE PARENTS
SIMPLY CAN'T MAKE THE TIME. TO
TAKE THEIR KIDS TO BE VACCINATED
THEY'RE WORKING MULTIPLE JOBS
IT'S JUST NOT. THEIR HIGHEST
PRIORITY COMPARED TO EVERYTHING
ELSE I HAVE GOING ON IN LIFE.
AND SO THE KID MAY NOT GET BACK
SENATE. WHERE THERE MIGHT BE A
DELAY OF SEVERAL MONTHS BEFORE
THEY'RE VACCINATED WHICH CAN
HAVE TERRIBLE CONSEQUENCES. WE
KNOW THAT SINCE MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY CALIFORNIA HAS
EXPERIENCED MORE THAN EIGHT
MILLION CONFIRMED CASES OF CODE.
AT ALMOST NINETY THOUSAND DEATHS
NINETY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
HAVE DIED. BOB SINCE DATA
DEMONSTRATES AN UNVACCINATED
PEOPLE ARE STILL ALMOST NINE
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO DIE FROM
CODED THAN PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE
THE ROOSTER DOES. NEARLY ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIA TEENAGERS ARE
UNVACCINATED FOR COVERT HAVING A
LARGE NUMBER OF UNVACCINATED
TEENS UNDERMINES PUBLIC HEALTH
AND INCREASES THE RISK OF
INFECTION HOSPITALIZATION AND
DEATH FOR THOSE KIDS BUT ALSO
FOR OTHERS AROUND THEM. THESE
LOW VACCINATION RATES KIND OF
DIRE CONSEQUENCES A RECENT STUDY
OF FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
YOUTH BETWEEN THE AGES OF TWELVE
AND SEVENTEEN PUBLISHED IN THE
NEW ENGLAND JOURNAL OF MEDICINE
FOUND THAT ALMOST ALL TEENAGERS
WHO NEED INTENSIVE CARE FOR
COVER NINETEEN WERE UNVACCINATED
AND ALL SEVEN WHO DIED. WERE
UNVACCINATED. THIS
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS ARE
PREVENTABLE TO ADD TO BE CLEAR.
THIS BILL IS NOT ONLY ABOUT CODE
THE CODE BAXEEN ABOUT OTHER
VACCINES AS WELL BUT WE KNOW THE
COVE IT IS FRONT AND CENTER
STILL BECAUSE THE PANDEMIC IS
NOT OVER- AND WALLS EMPIRICAL
EVIDENCE IS STILL EMERGING-
REGARDING THE IMPACTS OF COOKING
NINETEEN RELATED SCHOOL CLOSURES
ON YOUTH. MOST STUDIES HAVE
FOUND NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF THESE
CLOSURES ON TEAMS MENTAL HEALTH
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT THANK LAST
BASED ACADEMIC DISPARITIES AND
VACCINATION IS ONE METHOD OF
MAKING SURE THAT OUR SCHOOLS DO
NOT CLOSE DOWN. EMPOWERING YOUNG-PEOPLE WITH THE AUTONOMY TO
RECEIVE LIFE SAVING VACCINES
REGARDLESS OF THEIR PARENTS
BELIEFS OR WORK SCHEDULES IS
ESSENTIAL TO KEEPING STUDENTS IN
SCHOOL AND FOR THEIR PHYSICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH. COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SB EIGHT SIXTY SIX. WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY- ON IT'S A
GLOSSY ON- WHO'S AND- WITH TEENS
FOR VACCINES- ARE IN PARSA THE
FOUNDER OF TEENS FOR VACCINES.
GEORGE SOROS- AND AN ADVOCATE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND DEEMED ON BURKE-
AND I'M THE- UC DAVIS
PEDIATRICIAN AND BOARD MEMBER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA IMMUNIZATION
COALITION AND WE ALSO HAVE
PEOPLE AVAILABLE IF TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ARISE. OVER THE COURSE
OF THE HEARING THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT- IF THERE ARE THOSE WITH
AS OF THE PRESENT HERE IN THE
HEARING OF THAT APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE IF NOT- MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD QUEUE UP- BONTA.
KAILAS IN IRAN PARSA GEORGE
SOROS- AND DR DEAN BLOOMBERG.
ALL RIGHT HERE- IF YOU APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE I WILL- YOU'VE
GOT TWENTY MINUTES IN TOTAL IN
SUPPORT I WILL ANNOUNCE EVERY
FIVE MINUTE INTERVAL ALL RIGHT
THE FLOOR IS YOURS GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS ONLY TWO BLOCKS YEAH
I'M A PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATE
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AN
AMBASSADOR FOR TEENS ACCEDES THE
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS UNDER
EIGHTEEN. YET THOSE UNDER
EIGHTEEN MAKE UP 44% OF THE
VACCINE WITHIN OUR STATE I'M
HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF THE OVER
ONE MILLION UNVACCINATED TEENS
IN CA. WHO CAN'T RECEIVE
IMMUNIZATION DO BERRIES YOU CAN
ALLEVIATE. I'M HERE TO TELL YOU
WHY SB EIGHT SIX SIX WILL HELP
OVER A MILLION YOUNG PEOPLE AND
SAY THEY HAVE THE POWER TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR BODY. TO
GET BACKSEAT AND KEEP THEIR
COMMUNITY SAFE. I STARTED MY
JOURNEY IN VACCINE ADVOCACY
AFTER MY MOM REFUSED TO LET ME
GET BACK IN WITH THE FLU SHOT.
WHAT COMPANY BURKE OUT AYE THAR
LEASES TIRELESSLY URGE MY MOTHER
TO LET ME GET BACK NEEDED EVEN
CREATING SUCH A PRESENTATIONS.
EVERY WEEK WITH NEW DATA SHOWING
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS VACCINE.
OVERTIME I SEE THE SLIDE SHOW
WITH OVER TWO THOUSAND OTHER USE
WHO ALSO HAD VACCINE HESITANT
PARENTS. THIS ALLOWED ME TO SEE
THE TO REPERCUSSIONS
MISINFORMATION HAD ON RELAX. WE
KNOW VACCINES SAVE LIVES BECAUSE
I DID NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
VACCINATE MYSELF I LOST MY JOB.
THREE INTERNSHIP AND WAS UNABLE
TO SEE MY GRANDMA WHEN SHE WAS
INTUBATED. SOME STUDENTS OR EVEN
FORCE TO TAKE A GAP YEAR FROM
THEIR UNIVERSITY DUE TO THEIR
PARENTS NOT ALLOWING THEM TO GET
IMMUNIZED. FOR MONTHS I ISOLATE
MYSELF IN MY ROOM ONLY TAKING
ROUTINE WALKS TO NEARBY PARK
WITH FEAR OF RISKING THE LIVES.
OF MY HIGH RISK FAMILY MEMBERS.
LIKE OTHER CA KIDS I'VE
CONTINUED REMOTE LEARNING DUE TO
LIVING WITH HIGH RISK FAMILY
MEMBERS. MANY OVERLOOK THE
STUDENTS WHO ARE CURRENTLY STUCK
AT HOME DUE TO SCHOOLS NOT BEING
SAFE FOR THEM. STUDENTS ARE
MISSING OUT ON VITAL
OPPORTUNITIES AN EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCES. SIMPLY DUE TO THE
POLLING I THINK ISSUE THAT IS
VACCINATION. WE MUST NOT LET
TEENAGERS BE OPPRESSED ANY
LONGER. DO NOT BEING ABLE TO
MAKE THE CHOICE. CALIFORNIA CAN
BECOME A MORE EQUITABLE PLACE.
BY MAKING MUSICIAN READILY
AVAILABLE TO ALL STUDENTS TO SIT
AGAIN MISTER THEM WITHOUT THE
WORRY OF BACKLASH FROM PARENTS.
STUDENTS SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT THINGS THAT
IMPACT THEIR LIVES SO HAPPILY. I
ASK YOU TO CONSIDER THE STUDENT
WAS A GRAMMAR WITH LUNG CANCER
AT HOME. THE STUDENTS WHO MAY BE
HIGH RISK THEMSELVES THE CENTER
UNABLE TO. ATTEND SCHOOL.
ALIENATED FROM THE WORLD TO
SIMPLY DO THEIR VACCINATION
STATUS. WE MUST GIVE OUR TEAMS
THE RIGHT TO SAVE THEIR LIVES
AND OTHERS BY ALLOWING.
THEMSELVES TO CONSENT TO THEIR
OWN IMMUNIZATION. CALIFORNIA'S
MAY THE CHANGE. SOME OTHER
STATES HAVE ACCEPT THE- MADE
BEFORE THAT. AND THAT'S- EIGHT
SIX. BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS. AS THE EIGHT SIX SIX
GIVE THEM THE AUTHORITY TO MAKE
IT THEMSELVES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHTS ARE AND PARCEL.
TRYING TO TAKE THIS OFF. SURE
THREE OF GOOD MORNING AS HE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ARGHA PARSA AND I AM A NINTH
GRADER FROM SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA
AND I'M THE FOUNDER OF TEENS
VACCINES USED ORGANIZATION WITH
AMBASSADORS WITH ACROSS MANY
SEATS IN THE IN THE U. S. ALONE
THE LIFESAVING POWER OF VACCINES
AND EMPOWERING TEENS TO GET
VACCINATED. I'M HERE TODAY TO
VOICE MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB
EIGHT SIX SIX SO YOUNG PEOPLE
LIKE ME TWELVE AND OLDER.
CONSENSUSDOCS NATIONS SO WE CAN
LIVE WITHOUT THE FEAR ALL DEADLY
DISEASES TAKING AWAY OUR FUTURES
. I COUNTY TO ROCK SCENE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN DURING THE
HEIGHT OF THE MEASLES OUTBREAKS%
OF THAT YEAR WHEN MANY
DISTRAUGHT TEENS OUT BACK AND
HAS BEEN AN ANTI VAX PARENTS
WERE GOING TO READ IT AND OTHER
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS. TO KNOW
HOW TO GET VACCINES TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES. DURING THIS TIME
BROKE BALK A TEN YEAR OLD IN
ORANGE COUNTY. COULD GET
VACCINATED DUE TO HAVING A HEART
TRANSPLANT. BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T
GO TO SCHOOL BECAUSE PARENTS
BECAUSE MIDDLE VACCINATION RATES
WERE SO LOW IN ORANGE COUNTY DUE
TO SOME PARENTS REFUSING TO GET
THEIR CHILDREN VACCINATED. WHEN
READING OF THE STORY WAS
SHOCKING AND GUT WRENCHING TO ME
THAT CHILDREN TODAY FACE THE
SAME. DISEASES THAT PLAGUE US
FIFTY AND EVEN ONE HUNDRED YEARS
AGO AND EVER SINCE THEN I'VE
BEEN TIRELESSLY ADVOCATING FOR
EVERY CHILD'S RIGHT. TO GET
VACCINATED AGAINST DEADLY
DISEASES. WITH A CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC RAVAGING OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR OVER TWO YEARS
NOW. WITH UNPREDICTABLE
MUTATIONS OF THE VIRUS IN THIS
INFORMATION ON SOCIAL MEDIA
SWING PARENTS THE CRISIS FACED
BY BACKING HAS BY. ALL BACKING
HAS BEEN AN ANTI VAX PARENTS HAS
ONLY GOTTEN WORSE. WHEN TEENS
CAN PROTECT THEMSELVES THE LIVE
IN FEAR AND ISOLATION WORRIED
ABOUT CATCHING THE DISEASE
MISSING SCHOOL INFECTING FRIENDS
FOLDABLE GRANDPARENTS OUR
YOUNGER SIBLINGS. THIS IS NOT
ONLY A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE IT IS
A SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
FOR TEENS THAT WE SIMPLY CANNOT
AFFORD TO IGNORE ANY LONGER.
WHAT WOULD IT ALSO HIGHLIGHTED
SIGNIFICANT INEQUITIES. SO MANY
TEAMS HAVE PARENTS WHO ARE
WORKING TWO JOBS BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T GET THE NECESSARY
TRANSPORTATION TO GET VACCINATED
TEENS NEED EASY ACCESS TO
VACCINES. NOT ONLY IN SCHOOLS
BUT ALSO AFTER COLLECTIVITY
CENTERS AND PHARMACIES EVERY
YEAR WE LOOK SO MANY HEALTHY
TEENS TO FLU AND MENINGITIS. IT
SHOULD BE EASY PREVENTABLE
CANCER BUT OUR RATES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
AND LOW INCOME. COUNTIES ARE
BLESSING 20% LOWER CLOSE TO THE
80% GOAL THAT WE ASPIRE FOR.
COAL WOULD CONTINUE TO THREATEN
THE LIVES AND FUTURES. WE CANNOT
IGNORE THESE INEQUITIES ANYMORE
IT IS TIME WE TAKE ACTION IT'S
TIME WE'RE WE REMOVE BARRIERS
FOR ALL TEENS GET LIFESAVING
VACCINES AND HEALTH CARE.
EXISTING CALIFORNIA POLICY
ALREADY ALLOWS MINORS TWELVE AND
OLDER THE CONTENT OF TO
PREVENTATIVE MEDICAL CARE. IN
THE FORM OF VACCIES FOR HIV AND
HEPATITIS B. WE MUST EXTEND
THESE RIGHTS TO. STOP THE- WE
MUST EXTEND THESE RIGHTS TO ALL
IMMUNIZATIONS WITH TREMENDOUS
LEADERSHIP HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE HAVE SHOWN IN THE PAST
THAT WE CAN FORGE THE PATH AND
SET AN EXAMPLE. IT'S TIME TO
PASS THE SB EIGHT SIXTY SIX THE
TEENS TO STOCK SEEMS ACT
THIRTEEN CAN LIVE HAPPY AND
HEALTHY LIVES WITHOUT THE THREAT
OF DISEASE WHAT DO THE RIGHT
THING THANK YOU THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT BOB MISTER GEORGE SOROS.
YEAH. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GEORGE SOURIS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION I'M LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE I'M HERE REPRESENTING
OUR NEARLY FIFTY THOUSAND
PHYSICIAN MEMBERS. AT FIRST LIKE
TO THANK CENTER WINNER DR PAN
FOR BRING THIS TIMELY MEASURE
FORWARD. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE CHAIRED
COMMITTEE STAFF AND EVERYONE WHO
HAS WORKED ON THIS BILL. CMA IS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. AS PREVIOUSLY NOTED
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS FOR MINOR
TWELVE YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER TO
MAKE CERTAIN MEDICAL DECISION
WITHOUT PARENTAL CONSENT MOST
NOTABLY AS IT RELATES TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. THIS
PRESIDENT WAS FIRMLY UPTOWN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN WHEN THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ATKINS AUTHORED
IMPASSE ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINE
NINE WHICH ALLOW FOR ALL. FOR
MINOR TWELVE YEARS OF AGE AND
OLDER TO CONSENT TO MEDICAL CARE
RELATED TO PREVENTION OF
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASE-
MOST NOTABLY INCLUDING THE HPV
VACCINE. THIS MEASURE WAS LATER
SIGNED BY THEN GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN. SB EIGHT SIX SIX SIMPLY
EXPANDS AT A TINY TO FDA
APPROVED VACCINES. IT IS A
PRIORITY OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION TO SUPPORT
THE DEVELOPMENT OF LEGISLATION
THE FOCUS ON UNIVERSAL
ADOLESCENT IMMUNIZATION. THIS
BILL IS A KEY COMPONENT IN
ENSURING MINORS AGED TWELVE AND
OLDER ARE GIVEN THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT PROTECT
THEMSELVES AGAINST HARMFUL
DISEASE REGARDLESS OF PERSONAL
BARRIERS THAT ARE PRESENTED.
VACCINES ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH TOOL TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF OUR USE AND ENSURE
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE CAN
SAFELY NAVIGATE THE ONGOING
BATTLES KOPEN NINETEEN OR ANY
OTHER LIFE THREATENING DISEASE.
WE MAY BE FACED WITH IN THE
FUTURE. OUR POSITIONS AT CMA
SPENT A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
TIME DELIBERATING THIS
LEGISLATION. AND ULTIMATELY
DECIDED TO BE IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THIS EFFORT. I CAN ASSURE
YOU THE PHYSICIANS HAVE A DUTY
TO ALWAYS HAVE THE PATIENT'S
BEST HEALTH OUTCOMES. SB SIX
EXCUSE PHYSICIANS THE OPTION TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
VACCINATION WITH THE PATIENTS
WHO ARE TWELVE YEARS OF AGE AND
OLDER. THIS IS NOT A MANDATE.
MINORS AGED TWELVE AND OLDER
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO MAKE THIS
DECISION WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
HERE TODAY TO GIVE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THE AUTHORITY TO
MAKE THESE DECISIONS AND PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES. SENATORS THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT VOTE NO WE DON'T
TAKE THAT LIGHTLY BUT PLEASE
CHOOSE A SIDE OF SCIENCE EQUITY
AND CHOICE OUR COUNTRY IS
LOOKING TO CALIFORNIA TO BE A
LEADER ON THESE ISSUES AND WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY MAKE A
STATEMENT OF THIS LEGISLATION.
ESPECIALLY URGENT AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE. EXCUSE ME
DOCTOR BLOOMBERG. HAS CENTER-
BURKE ANOTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I'M DOCTOR DEAN BLOMBERG I'M A
SPECIALIST IN PEDIATRIC
INFECTIOUS DISEASES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I'M PLEASED TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT SIX SIX ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMUNIZATION
COALITION A NONPROFIT PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP DEDICATED TO
ACHIEVING AND MAINTAINING FULL
IMMUNIZATION PROTECTION FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO PROMOTE HEALTH
AND PREVENT SERIOUS ILLNESS
DISABILITY AND DEATH. ALL
VACCINES APPROVED BY THE FDA AND
ROUTINELY RECOMMENDED FOR
CHILDREN BY THE CDC ARE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT FOR INDIVIDUALS THE
BENEFITS OF ALL ROUTINELY
RECOMMENDED VACCINES FAR
OUTWEIGH THE SIDE EFFECTS. THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF VACCINES ARE
ASTOUNDING THE NUMBER OF MEASLES
CASES IN THE U. S. HAS DROPPED
BY NINETY NINE POINT 99% DUE TO
IMMUNIZATION. AND SIMILARLY
THERE HAVE BEEN MORE THAN 99%
DECREASES IN CASES OF TETANUS
GERMAN MEASLES AND SEVERE
INFECTIONS LIKE MENINGITIS
STUDENT HIM OR FROM OFFICE
INFLUENZA TYPE B. SMALLPOX HAS
BEEN ERADICATED FROM THE WORLD
AND POLIO ERADICATED FROM THE
WESTERN HEMISPHERE. WORLDWIDE
VACCINATION AS PREVENT AND
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION DEATHS
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND
200017405% DECREASE IN DEATHS
DID IT TEN VACCINE PREVENTABLE
DISEASE RELAPSE RELATIVE TO NO
VACCINATION. THIS IS SAVING MORE
THAN TWO MILLION DEATHS PER YEAR
. YET THESE VACCINE PREVENTABLE
DISEASES ARE STILL AROUND AND
THEY REMAIN A THREAT. IN MY
PRACTICE UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE
SEEN CHILDREN BRAIN DAMAGE DUE
TO MENINGITIS WITH MEANING A
CAUCUS OR LOSE AN ARM OR LEG DUE
TO SEPSIS OR BLOOD POISONING.
I'VE SEEN CHILDREN WITH SEVERE
CASES OF INFLUENZA IN THE ICU ON
VENTILATOR SO SOMETIMES ON HEART
LUNG BYPASS MACHINES AND
SOMETIMES DYING FROM THESE
PREVENTABLE DISEASES BECAUSE
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN IMMUNIZED. IN
TERMS OF COVERT NINETEEN IN
VACCINES MANY DO NOT REALIZE
THAT COVERT NINETEEN CAN BE
SERIOUS AND CHILDREN. TO DATE
MORE THAN TWELVE MILLION
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN INFECTED WITH
COVERT IN THE U. S. AND THIS IS
RESULTED IN MORE THAN FORTY
THOUSAND HOSPITALIZATIONS. AND
MORE THAN FIFTEEN HUNDRED DEATHS
IN TERMS OF THE AGE GROUP THAT
pWE'RE TALKING TODAY SIX HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE DEATHS HAVE
BEEN REPORTED BY THE CDC AND THE
TWELVE TO SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD AGE
GROUP. I'VE TAKEN CARE OF MANY
HOSPITALIZED CHILDREN WITH
COVERT SOME IN THE ICU AND
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE SEEN CHILDREN
DIE FROM COVERT HERE AND
CALIFORNIA. IMMUNIZATION RATES
ARE SUBOPTIMAL DUE TO A VARIETY
OF BARRIERS TO SELL ANY CHANGE
THAT FACILITATES CHILDHOOD
IMMUNIZATIONS WILL RESULT IN
IMPROVED HEALTH AND WELLNESS FOR
CHILDREN. TWELVE YEAR OLD
CHILDREN ARE ALREADY ABLE TO
CONSENT FOR HPV AND HEPATITIS B.
VACCINES. THE ONLY LOGICAL TO
EXTEND THIS CONSENT TO OTHER
LIFESAVING VACCINES SUCH AS THE
MENINGOCOCCAL MENINGITIS
VACCINE. UNFORTUNATELY COVERT
ACTION NATION RATES FOR CHILDREN
SIGNIFICANTLY LAG BEHIND OTHER
AGE GROUPS WITH LESS THAN 60% OF
TWELVE TO SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS.
RECEIVING TWO DOSES OF CODE
VACCINE. THIS IS A REAL TRAGEDY
SINCE THE CDC REPORTS THAT
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE TWELVE YEARS
OF AGE AND OLDER HAVE A TWENTY
TIMES INCREASED RISK OF DYING
FROM COVERT COMPARED TO THOSE
WHO ARE VACCINATED. AND THAT'S
WHY IT'S CRITICAL THAT
CALIFORNIA IMMUNIZATION POLICY
MAXIMIZES OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CHILDHOOD IMMUNIZATION INCLUDING
ALLOWING CHILDREN TWELVE AND
OVER TO CONSENT FOR THESE
POTENTIALLY LIFESAVING
PREVENTATIVE MEASURES. I'M
CONFIDENT THAT HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS WILL APPROPRIATELY
INFORM PATIENTS ABOUT VACCINES
WHEN THEY OBTAIN CONSENT. AND
PROVIDE THE APPROPRIATE APPROVED
VACCINE INFORMATION STATEMENT TO
THE VACCINE RECIPIENTS.
ROUTINELY RECOMMENDED VACCINES
ARE SAFE AND EFFECTIVE THEY KEEP
CHILDREN HEALTHY AND THEY SAVE
LIVES. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMUNIZATION
COALITION ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR S. B. EIGHT SIX SIX. TO
FACILITATE CHILDHOOD
IMMUNIZATION FOR HELP YOUR
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
- IN SEOUL DONE JUST. SO THAT WE
CONTINUE TO UNDERSTAND THE
GROUND RULES OF THE PROPONENTS
OF USED TWELVE MINUTES AND FORTY
SECONDS- I MENTIONED THE OUTSET
THAT THE OPPONENTS WITH EQUAL
TIME HOWEVER ALSO SORT OF BE
TWENTY MINUTES SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD. IN IN A FOR THE OPPONENTS
ARE TWENTY MINUTES. SO FOR THOSE
OF YOU WISHING TO QUEUE UP ON
THE PHONE TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE ONE.
ONE FOUR ZERO. BOB ALL RIGHT SO
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO NOW IS ONE
SECOND LET ME. SO AGAIN WE'RE
GOING TO DEPART FROM OUR USUAL
PROCESS WE'RE GONNA HAVE THE
PRIMARY OPPONENTS NOW- PROVIDE
THEIR TESTIMONY AND I'M FIVE
FOUR NAMES LISTED MARABELLA
TOWARD DAY MATT MCREYNOLDS
SABRINA SANDOVAL AND DON RICHARD
SAID. IF YOU ARE HERE IF YOU
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AND GIVE
US YOUR NAME AND THEN UP. GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY
AND THEN I WILL AND I FAILED TO
DO SO BEFORE BUT I'LL GIVE YOU
FIVE MINUTES SORT OF WARNINGS
ALL RIGHT ABSOLUTELY ABSENT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS NICOLE
PEARSON I'M AN ATTORNEY
PRINCIPAL AND FOUNDER FAX LAW TO
JUSTICE A LAW FIRM- ADVOCATING
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS HUMAN RIGHTS IN
THE CONSTITUTION THIS IS MY
CLIENT MERRY BELL DOOR T. I'M
HERE TO ASSIST WITH ANY
TRANSLATIONS. AND TO ANSWER ANY
LEGAL QUESTIONS- THAT THAT THAT
THE COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE AND AS
A PRELIMINARY MATTER I'D LIKE TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE TESTIMONY.
OF I THANK YOU THE TEST FOR
THESE- I THINK TEENAGERS THAT
ARE HERE. FOR THIS BILL YOU
DON'T GET BE HERE IN THIS
POSITION I'M MAMA BEAR WITH TWO
LITTLE KIDS. ADVOCATING AGAINST
THIS BILL IF YOU DON'T START OUT
LIKE YOURSELF AND IN HIGH SCHOOL
AND JUNIOR HIGH WITH THAT KIND
OF. FERVOR AND ADVOCACY AND
PASSION. HOWEVER I WANT TO ASK
YOU. HAVE THE TOLD YOU. THAT
CENTER WIENER TELL YOU. THAT IF
ANYTHING HAPPENS TO YOU WHEN YOU
GET A VACCINE IF YOU HAVE ANY
ADVERSE REACTION. AND THAT YOU
WILL NOT HAVE ANY COMPENSATION
FOR ANY OF ANY OF THOSE ADVERSE
REACTIONS. THEY TOLD YOU THAT
YOU CANNOT FILE A COMPLAINT WITH
THE NATIONAL VACCINE INJURY RAP
PROBE COMPENSATION PROGRAM. THAT
NO MINOR CAN FILE A CLAIM AND
THAT FOR THE TWELVE YEAR OLDS
THIRTY YEAR OLDS FOURTEEN YEAR
OLD AND FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS. WHO
WILL NEVER REACH THE AGE OF
MAJORITY IN THE THREE YEARS
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS TO FILE A
CLAIM WITH A COMPENSATION FUND.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THOSE CHILDREN
WILL BE LEFT HIGH AND DRY WITH
ZERO FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE IF
THEY EVER RECEIVE A VACCINE ANY
VACCINE. AND HAVE ANY NEGATIVE
REPERCUSSIONS. THIS THIS HARM
THIS DANGER IS COMPOUNDED BY
SENATE BILLS THANK A SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN NINETEEN WHICH IS ALSO
BEING CONSIDERED. BY THE SENATE
CURRENTLY IN THIS SESSION WHICH
WOULD SEAL THE MEDICAL RECORDS
OF MINORS WHO ARE ABLE TO
CONSENT TO MEDICAL PROCEDURES.
SO NOW WE WOULD HAVE YOUR
PARENTS REMOVED FROM THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT TO GIVE YOU THE
VACCINE. WOULD HAVE THE OPTION
TO SEAL YOUR RECORDS YOU WOULD
BE ABLE TO GET A VACCINE WITHOUT
THEIR KNOWLEDGE OR CONSENT. AND
THEN IF AND WHEN YOU IF GOD
FORBID YOU HAVE A MEDICAL
REACTION. THEY WOULD CALL YOUR
DOCTOR. AND THEY WOULD ASK THEM.
SOMETHING'S GOING ON I DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING SHE'S
HAVING A RASH IS HAVING A HARD
TIME BREATHING HER HEART HURTS
WILL EXPLAIN THE KIND OF
COMPLICATIONS HERE WITH MY
CLIENT MARABLE DUARTE. WHOSE SON
WAS IS WHO IS THIRTEEN YEARS OLD
WAS VACCINATED AT A VACCINATION
CLINIC. AT SCHOOL WITHOUT HER
KNOWLEDGE OR CONSENT. THEY WILL
NOT KNOW THE BE ABLE TO CALL
CALL PEDIATRICIAN- ASKED WHAT'S
GOING ON IN YOUR PEDIATRICIAN
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO TELL THEM.
THAT THEY GAVE YOU A VACCINE
THAT WASN'T APPROPRIATE FOR YOU
THAT YOUR PARENTS KNOWING YOU.
KNOWING THE LATE NIGHTS AT THE
STATE UP WITH YOU. WHEN YOU WERE
SIX WEEKS OLD AND YOU BROKE OUT
IN HIVES AND YOU HAD AN ADVERSE
REACTION TO THE IMAM MMR VACCINE
OR WHEN THEY STAYED UP EVERY
NIGHT FOR FIFTY. FOUR WEEKS
WATCHING TO MAKE SURE YOUR
BREATHING WHEN YOU HAVE AN
ADVERSE RIFAT. ADVERSE REACTION
TO THE DEATH AREA. MAXINE YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT THOSE TIMES THAT
WE STAYED UP WITH YOU. WONDERING
IF YOU WERE GOING TO LIVE
BECAUSE OF SOME ADVERSE REACTION
YOU HAD TO A VACCINE. BECAUSE
YOU WERE SO TINY YOU DON'T
REMEMBER AND BECAUSE WERE YOUR
PARENTS WE PROTECT YOU. AND WE
DON'T LIKE YOU KNOW. YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE TWELVE YEARS IN
THE BEST CASE SCENARIO. TWELVE
YEARS OF MEDICAL HISTORY TWELVE
YEARS. A TWENTY FOUR HOUR CARE.
THAT WE GIVE YOU WATCHING YOU
DAY IN DAY NIGHT. WHAT YOU PUT
ON YOUR BODY WHAT YOU PUT IN
YOUR BODY WHAT EXERCISE YOU DO
OR YOU DON'T DO. THE SOLUTION TO
THIS PROBLEM. I UNDERSTAND
SENATOR WIENER'S CONCERNS. IS
NOT TO REMOVE THE PARENT OR
LEGAL GUARDIAN. WHO IS THE ONLY
PERSON. THAT HAS ANY PERSONAL
KNOWLEDGE. ABOUT THESE
CHILDREN'S. TWELVE AT THE VERY
BEST. TWELVE YEARS OF MEDICAL
HISTORY. THERE ARE MANY
SOLUTIONS TO THIS PROBLEM. AND
IS NOT REMOVING THE ONLY PEOPLE
WHO HAVE THIS KNOWLEDGE TO HELP
THEIR CHILDREN EXCUSE ME
ACTUALLY TO MAKE. INFORMED
CONSENT. MEDICAL DECISION.
INFORMED CONSENT IN CALIFORNIA
REQUIRES THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
RECEIVING THE MEDICAL TREATMENT
REGARDLESS OF AGE. I UNDERSTAND
THE RISKS. AND THE BENEFITS
SPECIFIC TO THEM. THERE'S TWO
PRONGS THAT'S NUMBER ONE THAT
INFORMED. YOU MUST KNOW YOUR
MEDICAL HISTORY YOUR MEDICAL
CONDITIONS WHAT THE RISK FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE MEDICAL TREATMENT
YOU'RE ABOUT TO RECEIVE.
ALTERNATIVES AND THEN YOU MUST
CONSENT. AND IN CALIFORNIA
CONSENT IS ONLY VALID. IT EVEN
IF IT IS NOT OBTAINED UNDER
FRAUD. DURESS COERCION UNDUE
INFLUENCE. THE YOUNG LADY OVER
HERE MENTION SIX OTHER REASONS.
TRAVEL SEEING HER GRANDMA GOING
TO SCHOOL. AMONG OTHERS THAT SHE
WANTED TO GET THE VACCINE. IF
YOU'RE NOT SITTING IN YOUR
PEDIATRICIAN'S OFFICE THING. I'M
SCARED OF THIS VIRUS I WANT THAT
VACCINE IN MY BODY. TO PROTECT
ME FROM THAT VIRUS. YOU HAVE
BEEN COERCED. YOU HAVE BEEN.
SENT THERE ARE MOTIVATED TO GO
THERE UNDER DURESS UNDER DURESS
OF NOT PARTICIPATING IN EVEN
LONGER ON THE VARSITY FOOTBALL
TEAM. UNDER DURESS OF LOSING
YOUR SCHOLARSHIP. AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO COLLEGE TO
BE THE FIRST ONE IN YOUR FAMILY.
TO GRADUATE AND GO TO COLLEGE.
LOSING YOUR BEING COLD. BY ALL
OF YOUR B. AND IN. BY ELDERS A
POSITION OF WITH THE- WHO ARE
ADVISING. ONE SECOND TWENTY
THREE. I THINK WITNESSES SHOULD
BE DIRECTING THEIR COMMENTS THE
COMMITTEE NOT LECTURING WITNESS. ALL RIGHT SO INTERCEPTORS AS
IT IS A POINT OF ORDER YEAH YES
OF FOR THE WITNESSES YOUR
COMMENT SHOULD BE DIRECTED
COMMITTEE AND IN PARTICULAR TO
THE CHAIR APOLOGIZE NUMBER TWO-
YOU COULD DO NOW- USED OVER FIVE
MINUTES AND SO I DON'T HAVE YOU
LISTED AS A WITNESS OKAY- THAT
MEANS THAT THERE'S ABOUT FIFTEEN
MINUTES LEFT IN A AND I ASSUME
THAT MISS MARBLE TOWARDS AS-
WITNESS SHE'S THE PERFECT OUT
SHE'S THE PERFECT ALL RIGHT TO
TELL YOU I DON'T I'M SPEAKING TO
AND I APOLOGIZE. I'LL MAKE
MYSELF AVAILABLE TO HAVE FRESH
OF FOUR WITNESSES SO NOW YOU
HAVE THREE MORE WITNESSES OKAY
MARYLAND WORKED WITH HELLO. MY
NAME IS MONEY AVAILABLE AT THE-
I AM A SINGLE PARENT OF. SIX ONE
OF THEM I HAVE HIS NAME IS
MOSES. I'M GONNA TELL YOU LITTLE
BIT OF STUFF WOULD HAVE. TO MY
SON THAT SCHOOL- ONE TIME HE
CAME HOME FROM SCHOOL AND HE
SAYS MOM- I HAVE. THEY GAVE ME
PEAK THAT SCHOOL. SO I SAID OH
THAT'S REALLY GOOD ACTUALLY I
WAS REALLY HAPPY FOR HIM. BUT
THEN HE SAYS MOM I GOT IT FOR AN
EXCHANGE OF PIZZA. SO I SAID-
AND HOW DID THAT HAPPEN. HE'S
LIKE WELL. THE NURSE TOLD ME TO
SIGN MY NAME SIGN YOUR NAME FOR
ANY FOR A SLICE OF PIZZA. MY
HEARTFELT- I HAD NOTES BUT I'M
GONNA JUST BECAUSE MY HEART MY
HEART BROKE BECAUSE MY CHILD
SINCE HE WAS TWO THREE FOUR HE
HAD A BLEEDING DISORDER HE
ALWAYS SUFFER FROM BLEEDING FROM
HASNA HARPER YOU KNOW THE
TENSION OF HIM BRILLIANT SO GOOD
. SO WHEN THAT HAPPENED- WHEN
ALL THIS VACCINE WAS COMING I
WASN'T READY FOR HIM TO TAKE THE
VACCINE I ACTUALLY WANTED TO
HAVE MORE INFORMATION MORE
INFORMATION FOR HIM. I WANTED TO
KNOW IF HE WAS READY FOR HIM TO
HELP THE SHOT. SO THE SURPRISE
THAT HAPPENED YOU KNOW HE GOT A
SHOT IN SCHOOL. AS A AS A PARENT
IT FEELS REALLY REALLY I'M I'M
REALLY HURT I'M REALLY SAD I AM
VERY- IT SEEMS LIKE THEY TOOK MY
RIGHTS THEY TOOK YOU KNOW.
EVERYTHING I FELT REALLY BAD
REALLY I DIDN'T HAVE THE PUTS
POSITION TO EVEN SPEAK FOR MY
SON- HAVE THAT SPECIAL RIGHTS
FOR HIM TO SEE IF HE'S GONNA GET
SHOT OR GET GET THE BACKSEAT ARE
NOT. AFTER THESE. YOU KNOW
PERIOD OF TIMES I SEEN MY SON-
ILLUZION HAS HELD. HARDER TO
BREATHE HE WILL HAVE BRUISES IN
HIS SKIN. HE WAS CONSTANTLY
BLEEDING HIS BLEEDING INCREASE
TO MAYBE FIVE OR FOUR TIMES A
WEEK. HEADACHES ALL THE TIME
TIREDNESS. HE COULDN'T DO P. E.
HIS P. E. WORSE. INSTEAD OF
RUNNING HE WAS WALKING LAPS NOW
INSTEAD OF HIM WAKING UP EARLY
FOR SCHOOL IT WAS REALLY HARD
FOR HIM TO WAKE UP FOR SCHOOL.
HE STARTED GETTING MENTALLY
MENTALLY EMOTIONALLY- HOME SAD
DEPRESSED COULDN'T HAVE THE SAME
ACTIVITIES THAT HE HAD BEFORE.
HE DIDN'T HAVE A NORMAL LIFE
ANYMORE. MY CONCERN IS. THIS IS
VERY CONCERNING TO ME AS A
PARENT- KNOWING THAT I KNEW HIS
BACKGROUND HIS HEALTH IS WHAT
MADE IT WORSE. THAT HE GOT
VACCINATED WITHOUT MY CONSENT.
THERE'S MOMENT SAID DIARY HENDO
HAVE TO AWAKEN NEXT TO HIM TO
SEE IF HE'S BREATHING THERE'S
MOMENTS I FEAR THAT- HE'S IN
SCHOOL THINKING HE'S IF HE'S
GONNA MAKE IT TO MAKE IT HOME IS
HE GOING TO BE OKAY- CONSTANTLY
BE CRYIN SUFFERING. AS WELL FOR
ME IT'S BEEN REALLY HARD. AND- I
DON'T KNOW IF HE'S IN A IT- IT'S
PAINFUL. IT'S VERY PAINFUL. IT'S
VERY PAINFUL. I FEEL BAD IN THAT
AGE SIX STILL DON'T HAVE THAT
MENTALITY OR THAT RIGHT NOW IS
TO CHOOSE. IF THEY'RE OKAY OR
HEALTHY ENOUGH TO MAKE THAT
DECISION. I AM BEGGING YOU NOT
TO LET THIS. THE BILL PASSED IN
HEARD MORE CHILDREN THE WAY MINE
HAS HURT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER WARD DAY ALL RIGHT- NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. MIKE IS RIGHT
HERE. FOR THANK YOU. GOOD%
MORNING MR SHARED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MATTHEW MCREYNOLDS
HERE SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY WITH
PACIFIC JUSTICE INSTITUTE A
CENTER FOR PUBLIC POLICY JUST A
FEW QUICK POINTS PRIMARILY
ADDRESSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THE CAME OUT YESTERDAY
THE SIMPSON REALLY IMPORTANT
DISTINCTIONS THAT NEED TO BE
DRAWN FIRST OF ALL AS TO THIS
NOTION THAT WE'RE BUILDING ON
EXISTING LAW. LET'S NOT KID
OURSELVES SB EIGHT SIXTY SIX
WHATEVER ELSE YOU MIGHT THINK OR
SAY ABOUT IT IS NOT ABOUT
EXPANDING CHOICE IT IS NOT ABOUT
INFORMED CONSENT AND HOW DO WE
KNOW THAT WE KNOW THAT FIRST OF
ALL BY LOOKING AT ONE OF THE KEY
DECISIONS IN THIS AREA THAT THE
ANALYSIS FOCUSED ON AND WE
BROUGHT UP IN OUR OPPOSITION
LETTER AS WELL THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS VERSES
LUNDGREN DECISION. AND WHAT THAT
. DECISION DID WITH A LOT OF THE
OTHER LEGISLATION THAT'S BEEN
MENTIONED DID. WAS EXPAND TRUE
CHOICE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN AREAS
SUCH AS VACCINES AND MEDICAL
CARE. WELL THANKS TO THE
COMPULSORY. SCHOOL ATTENDANCE
LAWS SB EIGHT SIXTY SIX WILL
ENSURE WE FOR ALLUSIONS TO THIS
FROM. THE OTHER SIDE TODAY THAT
THERE IS NO REAL CHOICE THE
STUDENTS ARE GIVEN AS THE
VACCINES. IF YOU WANT TO TRULY
GIVE KIDS A CHOICE GIVEN THE
CHOICE. GIVE THEM A CHOICE TO
ATTEND SCHOOL WITH OR WITHOUT A
VACCINE. THAT'S INFORMED CONSENT
AND THAT'S TRUE CHOICE. SO A LOT
MORE COULD BE SAID ABOUT THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY DECISION AS
WELL AS THE- THE BOOTH DECISION
FROM DC WHICH JUST RECENTLY
STRUCK DOWN. A VERY SIMILAR
MEASURE UNFORTUNATELY THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AT RESORTS TO
IGNORING MOST OF THE ISSUES IN
THAT CASE AS WELL AS PYRIDINE
THE LOSING. ARGUMENTS BUT I FIND
IT VERY TELLING THAT THE FEDERAL
JUDGE THERE- ACTUALLY ECHOED
MANY OF THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT FORWARD- BY IN POINT
YOU FOR TODAY AS WELL AS IN THE-
OPPOSITION STATEMENTS WEB URGE
YOU TO TAKE. A MUCH MUCH CLOSER
LOOK AT NOT ONLY THE DEC'S
DECISION BUT AND DECISION THE
CANNOT JUST LAST WEEK FROM THE
KANSAS CITY AREA- THE HOLDING.
THIRTY CASE COULD GO FORWARD
AGAINST WALMART FOR AT
VACCINATING AS TO FIGHT CHILD.
WITHOUT THEIR PARENTS CONSENT. A
ACCOUNT OF THOSE THAT YOU JUST
IT FEW OTHER QUICK POINTS. THE
COMEDIAN ALICE NO. THAT THAT
PARENTS ARE. OPPOSING VACCINES
OR VACCINE HESITANT BECAUSE
THEY'RE SUFFERING FROM
MISINFORMATION THERE UNDER
RESOURCE AND THEY'RE OVER BIRD.
PERRANCE HERE ARE PLAGUED BY
MISINFORMATION THE PLAGUE BIKE
MISSING INFORMATION SUCH AS THE
MISSING INFORMATION ON ACTUAL
VACCINE STATS NOT ABOUT THE
ENTIRE POPULATION AS YOU SEE IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ELSEWHERE
IN THE DEBATE BUT SPECIFIC TO
KIDS ABOUT THE DATA FROM THE
CDPH ITSELF. FROM THE VACCINE
ADVERSE EVENTS REPORTING SYSTEM
WITH THE HHS ON ALL OF THE
ADVERSE EFFECTS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCED THOUSANDS OF THEM-
BY KIDS TAKING A SERIOUS-
SERIOUS EFFECTS HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND OTHER MAJOR MAJOR EFFECTS
THAT HAVE RESULTED FROM GETTING
VACCINES. IF YOU WANT TRUE
INFORMED CHOICE INFORMED CONSENT
YOU'VE GOT TO MAKE THAT PART OF
THE DEBATE AND IS COMPLETELY
MISSING SO SOME MISINFORMATION
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MISSING
INFORMATION. AS FAR AS BEING.
OVER BURDENED. IT'S ARE
OVERBURDENED FOR SURE THERE-
OVERBURDENED BY THIS BODY AT
CONTINUING TO TAKE AWAY THEIR
RIGHTS CONTINUING TO LOAD THEM
DOWN WITH THE REGULATIONS LISTEN
TO YOUR CONSTITUENTS LISTEN TO A
HEARTFELT TESTIMONY THAT WE'VE
WE'VE JUST HEARD. PLEASE DON'T
TAKE US BACK A HUNDRED YEARS
WHICH IS WHERE WE STARTED WITH
THE COMPULSORY VACCINE-
DECISIONS. PLEASE ACKNOWLEDGE
THREE HUNDRED YEARS OF PROGRESS
THAT HAVEBEEN MADE WITH OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS SINCE THIS
IS A DECISION IN NINETEEN TWENTY
TWO THE- PROGRESS THAT'S BEEN
MADE FOR PARENTAL RIGHTS FOR
FREE EXERCISE RIGHTS EVEN FOR
STUDENTS RIGHTS IN THE FIRST
AMENDMENT ROUND. ALL OF THAT IS
AT RISK IF WE GO BACK A HUNDRED
YEARS IN REVERT TO THE
DISCREDITED POLICIES OF A BY
GONE ERA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER MCREYNOLDS ALL RIGHT- ONE
LAST WITNESS. TO HOW MUCH TIME
IS UP YOU USE FORTY MINUTES AND
TWENTY ONE SECONDS GO AHEAD.
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY
TESTIMONY TODAY MY NAME IS
SABRINA SOUND OF ALL I AM A
PRACTICING SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST
THE SEVEN YEARS. MY WHOLE LIFE
AND CAREER REVOLVES AROUND BEING
A RESOURCE TO CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN THAT ROLE I SSL
CHILDREN'S COGNITIVE SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL AND ADAPTIVE LEVELS OF
FUNCTIONING IMPACTS THEIR
ABILITY TO LEARN AND FUNCTION AN
EDUCATIONAL SETTING. I'M HERE
TODAY TO GIVE MY PROFESSIONAL
ASSESSMENT AS TO WHY SB EIGHT
SIX SIX IS NOT SOUND POLICY MY
TWO GREATEST CONCERNS FROM A
PSYCHOLOGY PERSPECTIVE RELATE TO
TEENS DECISION MAKING INTO
CHRISTIAN. SB EIGHT SIX SIX PUTS
THE RESPONSIBILITY ON MINORS OF
AGE TWELVE YEARS OR OLDER TO
MAKE POTENTIALLY LIFE ALTERING
MEDICAL DECISIONS WITHOUT
PARENTAL CONSENT WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME OPENING THEM UP TO
POSSIBLE CREATION BALLING IMPAIR
PRESSURE THIS BILL IS UNLIKE ANY
OTHER IN CALIFORNIA IN SPITE OF
CLAIMS THAT WE HAVE PRESIDENT
WITH HPV ARE HAPPY VACCINES.
EXPANDING MINOR CONSENT TO ALL
FDA APPROVED VACCINES ESPECIALLY
TO COVET NINETEEN VACCINES
EXPOSES TEENS TO MEDICAL
CONVERSION THROUGH INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS AND FOOD BASED REWARDS
IF THE TEAMS ARE TWELVE YEAR OLD
BRAIN DEVELOPMENTALLY CLIP TO
MAKE MEDICAL DECISIONS THERE ARE
THREE AREAS OF THE BRAIN
RESPONSIBLE FOR DECISION MAKING
FIRST IS THE PREFRONTAL CORTEX
WHICH IS THE PRIMARY AREA OF THE
BRAIN RESPONSIBLE FOR RATIONAL
DECISIONS. AND FOR PROCESSING
RIGHT FROM WRONG AND BOTH LONG
AND SHORT TERM CAUSE AND EFFECT
A FRIEND FACT THE PREFRONTAL
CORTEX IS NOT FULLY DEVELOPED
UNTIL ABOUT AGE TWENTY FIVE
SECOND IS THE MAKE DELAY WHICH
IS IMPULSIVE PART OF THE BRAIN
AND DECISION MAKING IT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR INSTINCTIVE
REACTIONS SUCH AS FIGHT OR
FLIGHT. AND FOR STORING BOTH BAD
AND HIGHLY REWARDING EXPERIENCES
A FUN FACT TO THE MIDDLE A
MIDDLE. IS ALREADY DEVELOPED AT
BIRTH. THERE'S A STUDY DONE OUT
OF MY LEAN HOW. BRAIN AND CENTER
AND BOSS THAT CAN. TO BRAIN TO
THOSE OF A DAHLE WHEN FACE EMAIL
DEATH. THE RESULTS SHOW THAT
FULLY DEVELOPED ADULT BRAINS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO OVERRIDE THE
IMPULSIVENESS OF THEM MAKE TO
LET BY USING THEIR PREFRONTAL
CORTEX OR THE RATIONAL PART OF
THE BRAIN. ADELIN SEN I'M SORRY
ADOLESCENCE MOSTLY PROCESS
INFORMATION WITH THE MAKE DELAY
AND DO NOT FULLY HAVE THE COULD
KEEP ABILITY TO OVERRIDE. THAT
AREA WITH THE RATIONAL BRAIN
THIS IS IMPORTANT WHEN
CONSIDERING TEAMS MAKING MEDICAL
DECISIONS. THEY SIMPLY DO NOT
HAVE FULLY DEVELOPED DECISION
MAKING SKILLS NEEDED TO WEIGH
THE RISKS AND BENEFITS. AND
MAKING A TRULY INFORMED DECISION
AS LOWER ACTIVITY IN THE FRONTAL
LOBE CAN LEAD TO POOR JUDGMENT
AND REACTIONARY DECISION MAKING
MAKING. WHICH BRINGS ME TO MY
CONCERN OF COURSE ASIAN BALLING
IMPAIR PRESSURE. WE NOW IN ORDER
TO MAKE A WHILE WAITED OUT
DECISION YOU NEED TO HAVE THE
SKILLS BRAIN MECHANICS AND
KNOWLEDGE BASE ARTICLES FOR
THESE AND THEN THAT. IT HAS BEEN
A WELL ESTABLISHED THAT ALL OF
US AT ONE POINT ESPECIALLY
CHILDREN WANT TO PLEASE AND OBEY
THOSE IN AUTHORITY WHEN CHILDREN
HEAR MESSAGES THAT THEY WILL GET
SICK AND MY SKEPTICAL THAT
VACCINE TO PROTECT GRAMMA. THEY
ARE VERY IMPRESSIONABLE THE
DESIRE TO GET THE COVERT VACCINE
BY THE CHILD IS NOT BORNE OUT OF
SINCERE DESIRE FOR THE VACCINE.
BUT RATHER BECAUSE OF THE
INTENSE GO HERE SEVEN BOWLING
TACTICS TACTICS AT THAT AT THE
READY. NEVER BEFORE WITH ANY
VACCINE IN OUR LIFETIME HAVE WE
SEEN THIS MEDICAL CONFUSION AND
OUR CHILDREN ARE BEARING THE
BRUNT OF IT. WELL THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS POINT OUT THAT UNDER
CURRENT LAW MINORS AT AGE TWELVE
YEARS AND OLDER MAY CONSENT TO
MEDICAL CARE. RELATED TO THE
PREVENTION OF SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASE WHICH
INCLUDED HPV OR HAPPY VACCINES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE NOT
PREVIOUSLY OFFERED INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS. FOOD BASED REWARDS ARE
POP UP CLINICS FOR VACCINES
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN OFFERED PIZZA
ICE CREAM AND OTHER ENTICING
INCENTIVES IT SENSE IT AND SORRY
INCENTIVES IF THEY COMPLY AND
GET THE COVERT VACCINE. THE BILL
IN DALLAS DESPITE OUT THAT THE
AUTHOR MY AND THE BILL TO ADD.
RAIL FOR TO MINORS. WHOSE
ABILITY TO CAN. MY BE COPPER BE.
DISABILITY ORGANIZATIONS I WORK
WITH SEVERE US SERVE MINORS WHO
ARE LIKELY TO BE CONSERVED AT
THE AGE OF MAJORITY. DUE TO
SEVERELY IMPACT TO FALL
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENTS.
PERMITTING A MINOR WITH
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES
DISABILITIES TO CONSENT TO
VACCINATION AND THE ABSENCE OF A
PARENT OR GUARDIAN. RAISES
ETHICAL CONCERNS AS WELL AS
CONCERNS OVER INFORMED CONSENT.
MINOR STUDENTS WITH EXCEPTIONAL
NEEDS HAVE NEVER BEFORE FACED
THE POSSIBILITY OF MEDICAL CORPS
HERE'S COURAGE AND- AN EXCHANGE
FOR SHORT TERM INCENTIVES IN A
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT. ABSENT
PARENTAL CONSENT AND REVIEW OF
COMPLICATED MEDICAL HISTORIES
VACCINATION OF SUCH CHILDREN
COULD BE A DEVASTATING HEALTH
IMPACT. IN MY PROFESSIONAL
OPINION CHILDREN AGE TWELVE AND
UP WHETHER NARAL TYPICAL OR WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS ARE NOT.
PSYCHOLOGICALLY FULLY EQUIPPED
TO MAKE MEDICAL DECISIONS AND
SHOULD NOT BE SUBJECTED TO
MEDICAL CHRISTIAN. FOR THE
REASONS STATED I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NO VOTE ON SB EIGHT SIX
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
SON OF ALL OF THE THOSE ARE THE
FOUR WITNESSES I UNDERSTAND IS
THE FIFTH WITNESS MISS
RICHARDSON WHOSE- FLOWN HERE TO
TESTIFY. SO MISS RICHARDSON- GO
AHEAD- THERE'S NOW BEEN NINETY
MINUTES AD THIRTY TWO SECONDS
THAT HAVE. BEEN USE GO AHEAD AND
TAKE THREE MINUTES AND THAT WILL
THEN EXHAUSTS THE FIVE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S DON RICHARDSON THE
DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY FROM THE
NATIONAL VACCINE INFORMATION
CENTER HERE TO VOICE OPPOSITION
WARNER FORTY APPEARED IN THE ICY
AND WE ARE MISSION BASE TO
PROTECT INFORMED CONSENT TO
VACCINATION. I'M NOT GONNA
TRYING GO THROUGH THINGS REALLY
QUICK IN THE OFFICE SCRIPT HERE
TO JUST GIVE YOU THE PERTINENT
INFORMATION. THAT HASN'T BEEN
COVERED BEFORE YOUR KIDS ARE
DEFINITELY VULNERABLE TO PEER
PRESSURE THE CHILD PSYCHOLOGIST
MENTION THAT BUT WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IF THIS PASSES HIS KIDS
ARE GONNA BE TARGETED AND
MARKETED TO GET THE VACCINES.
AND THIS IS IN STARK CONTRAST TO
LAWS IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW
THAT PREVENT THE MARKETING AND
SELLING OF RISK CONTAINING
PRODUCTS TO KIDS LIKE TOBACCO
VAPING MATERIALS PREPAID BB GUNS
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES EVEN TATTOOS
WHICH ARE STILL INJECTED BUT
THEY'RE JUST DIES. KIDS CAN'T
GET THEM AND WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO THE CHILDREN WHO
TESTIFIED TODAY THEY HAVE BEEN
BLESSED NOT TO AS A PARENT HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THE VACCINE
REACTION SO IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE
THAT THEY GET EXCITED WHEN THEY
SEE TO TALK VIDEOS AND SNAPCHATS
ABOUT. HEY LET'S GET OUR
VACCINES BUT THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE
DEALING WITH A CHILD WITH
LONGTIME DISABILITY THAT
CONGRESS AFFIRMED THROUGH THE
NATIONAL VACCINE INJURY ACT. I
DO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT CENTER
WIENER ON THE WEBSITE WHEN HE'S
PROMOTING THE BILL HE IS
BRINGING UP SOME STATES AS
EXAMPLES BUT WHAT HE DOES NOT
DISCLOSE TO YOU IS THAT FOUR OUT
OF FIVE OF THE STATES THAT HE
BRINGS UP. THOSE LAWS WERE
PASSED IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
SEVENTIES REALLY TARGETED
TOWARDS REPRODUCTIVE AN
EMERGENCY ROOM HEALTH THINKING
NEVER SPECIFICALLY. MENTIONED
VACCINES AND AT THAT TIME THERE
WERE ONLY THREE TAX ON THIS. NOW
THEIR SUPPORT. THEY NEVER COME.
THE SLIDE. AND THOSE FOR. THAT
WOULD HAVE THIS BLUE. IN INFO.
VACCINE SCHEDULE THROUGH. THE
OTHER STATE THAT HE MENTIONS ARE
NOT STATE LOCATIONS DC WAS
ALREADY MENTIONED BY THE LAWYER
FROM THE PACIFIC JSTICE
INSTITUTE THOUGHT LAW WAS STRUCK
DOWN BY FEDERAL COURT ALSO
CONGRESS HE NEVER CONTEMPLATED.
FOR CHILDREN TO BE MAKING THESE
DECISIONS AT ALL AS A MATTER OF
FACT THAT I RIGHT ON THE
NATIONAL INJURY. ACT OF NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX WHEN IS PASSED IT
STATE THAT BEFORE THE
ADMINISTRATION VACCINES TO CHILD
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER SHALL GIVE
A COPY OF THE CDC'S VACCINE
INFORMATION MATERIALS TO THE-
PARENT OR LEGAL REPRESENTATIVE.
ANY CHILD TO WHOM THE PROVIDER
INTENDS TO ADMINISTER SUCH A
VACCINE ALSO ONE PC WEBSITE THE
CONFIRM THIS IN THEIR QUESTIONS
AND ANSWERS WHERE DOES THE
PARENT HAVE TO BE GIVEN THIS
BEFORE VACCINATION. AND THE
ANSWER IS A CLEAR YES THAT IS
WHAT FEDERAL LAW HAS OUTLINES.
ALSO CONVERSE DID HAVE TO
CONGRESSIONAL HEARINGS IN EARLY
MARCH AND OF TWENTY NINETEEN AND
THE ONLY SIDE REPRESENTED WAS
THE TEAM'S SIDE NAY EVEN HAD A
KID WHO COMPLAINED ON REDDIT
THAT HIS MOM DIDN'T LET HIM GET
VACCINATED. THE PROBLEM WAS THIS
STARTED WITH MEDIA AND A WHOLE
BUNCH OF LAWS BEING FILED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN SEVEN STATES
ELEVEN TWENTY TWENTY SIX STATES
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND NINE
STATES INCLUDING CALIFORNIA
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WITH THIS
BODY HAS TO UNDERSTAND RECOGNIZE
IS THAT THE STATES HAVE ALL
CATEGORICALLY WAS REJECTED GO
AHEAD. THESE PROVISIONS. SO I
I'LL SAY THAT WE KNOW THESE KIDS
THEIR TIME. BEING TOLD BY ADULTS
WHO JUST SAYING TO DRUG. AND
WHAT WE'RE NOT TRYING TO DO IS
ACTUALLY GOING AND KEEPING
CURRENT RIGHT KIDS TO GO GET
DRUGS. ARE ABOUT PERSONAL LIFE
WITHOUT PER. THANK YOU FOR BY
OKAY- NOW- WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
IN OPPOSITION. OF FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY. BY
PROVIDING THEIR NAME YOUR NAME.
YOUR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION WE'RE NOT GOING TO-
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION TERMS OF THE LINE SO
IF YOU JUST LINE UP AT THE
MICROPHONE- IN GIVE US YOUR NAME
YOUR FILIATION YOUR POSITION.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE MCCANN
UNDER WOULD ON BEHALF OF THE
CLOVIS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
GOVERNING BOARD AND
SUPERINTENDENT IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. HELLO TO
THE SECULAR FOUND COFOUNDER
FREEDOM ANGELS REPRESENTATIVE OF
FLEX IT IN OPPOSITION. TARBOLTON
CO FOUNDER FREEDOM ANGELS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. BIELECKI LACK
FOUNDER OF HOPE DEALERS IN
ACTION AND I STRONGLY FEEL. POST
THIS BILL THANK YOU. RACHEL
IVERMECTIN GATE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB EIGHT SIX SIX THANK YOU.
QUINTANILLA BACK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH COALITION
ADVOCACY OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE DEGREE I'M AN RN FROM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY I'M HERE IN
REPRESENTATION OF TAKE A STANCE
STANISLAUS SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
LIBERTY COALITION FOUND THAT
NURSES FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B. EIGHT
SIX SIX THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
AMY BONTA I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
PERK PROTECTION THE EDUCATIONAL
RIGHTS OF KIDS AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
ALLISON THROW PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA FREEDOM KEEPERS AND
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ELENA AND I AM A
MEMBER OF THE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
LIBERTY COALITION. AND I HIGHLY
OPPOSES ANTI FAMILY BILL THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS JENNY GREAT I'M
A REGISTERED NURSE AND A MOTHER
ON BEHALF OF MY BROTHER IN EVERY
OTHER YOUNG MAN WHO'S
EXPERIENCED MYOCARDITIS. ACE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. TORCHE SHAFT- FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA REPUBLIC I SCHOOL
TEACHER AND A MOTHER OF TWO
TODDLERS STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
VERONICA I AM THE FOURTH
GENERATION COME CALIFORNIA
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA AND I IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT
SIX SIX I HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS THANK YOU. MICHELLE VERA
TOMLINSON AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE CENTRAL VALLEY
LIBERTY BELLS AND TASKS TAKE A
STAND STANISLAUS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED. BILL EIGHT SIX SIX
THANK YOU. THERE JOSH WILL
COLEMAN FROM ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA FATHER OF THE VACCINE
INJURED CHILD IN THE CO FOUNDER
OF V. IS FOR VACCINES. THE
WORLD'S LARGEST VACCINE RISK
PUBLIC EDUCATION CAMPAIGN AND-
REPRESENTING OVER TWO HUNDRED
AND TEN THOUSAND PARENTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN DISTRICT
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU. KERRIE BENTON WITH
SACRAMENTO FREEDOM COALITION AND
STAND UP SACRAMENTO THANK YOU
OPPOSE THANK YOU. RACHEL KATANA
FOUNDER AT ANYTIME IS USD FOR
FREEDOM AND MEMBERS STAND UP
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND WE OPPOSE
THANK YOU. HELLO KRYNN WILLOW
I'M A CO FOUNDER TAKE A STAND
STANISLAUS AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB EIGHT SIX SIX THANK
YOU. COURTNEY PETERS FROM SERIES
MON STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHT SIX
SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU. WHEN
THE BLOOM REGISTERED NURSE
ORGANIZING DIRECTOR PROTECT US I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THIS
WOMEN'S. THANK YOU. CATHERINE
FLORES MARTIN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA IMMUNIZATION
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MICHAEL LEACH MICHAEL
LEE CHANG REDONDO UNION HIGH
SCHOOL IN REDONDO BEACH AND I AM
PROUD TO SUPPORT SB EIGHT SIX
SIX THANK YOU. MY NAME IS A WE
NEXT TIME FOR IT I'M SORRY
AFFIRMING ON THE BEACH AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS ISSUED UPON I'M
WITH PROTECT US AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
CHILES GILES FROM SACRAMENTO- I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. GABRIELLE IN GRAHAM FOUNDER
OF STAND UP SACRAMENTO COUNTY
REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF
PARENTS IN THE COUNTY MOTHER OF
A VACCINE AND YOUR CHILD I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS SAMANTHA UNITE
TRACY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. NATHAN PEERS
PRIVATE HOME EDUCATORS OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. KAREN AMAZON DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS FOR FREEDOM KEEPERS
UNITING- BUT HE KNOWS COALITION
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SIX X.
THANK YOU. HI CHRISTY THE BILL
THAT I PURCHASED FROM EDUCATE
ADVOCATE WITH THEIR SPECIAL
NEEDS FAMILIES AND A VOICE FOR
CHOICE ADVOCACY WE OPPOSE THANK
YOU. I AM WIENER FRANZ I'M FROM
MARIN COUNTY. I'M A MOM AND A
FORMER TEACHER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
CHANGE HAILING FROM SACRAMENTO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
PARENTS FOR CHOICE WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. JESSICA BAR
SODI AN ATTORNEY- FROM OPEN
CALIFORNIA MOM ANIMALS TO
AFFILIATED WITH THE FAX
L'ACTRICE JUSTICE AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU. HI
SUSANNAH GREESON ROBBINS I'M
FROM NEVADA CALIFORNIA AND I'M A
MOTHER OF A VACCINE INJURED
CHILD AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS DR
TERESA KONG I'M AN ADULT
PSYCHIATRIST I LIVE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS RUTH CURIEL AND I'M A
GRANDMA OF SIX AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. WHAT. HI AND
HEATHER WHITE AND I AM I AM. A
SUPPORTER OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
COALITION ADVOCACY GROUP AND I'M
ALSO CONSTITUENTS OF HONORABLE
SENATOR BRIAN DAHLE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT SEE NO ONE ELSE
HERE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
WISHING TO TESTIFY EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. MODERATOR
WILL NOW TURN TO THE PHONE
pLINES- WE WILL- PROVIDE EACH
SIDE SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION-
EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME- SEVENTY
FIVE MINUTES OF MY GUESS IS THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE WISHING TO TESTIFY EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION- I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT. WE WILL ONLY TAKE
SEVENTY FIVE MINUTES OF-
TESTIMONY WHERE YOU PROVIDE YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL- SO
UNFORTUNATELY OF THAT MEANS THAT
SOME OF YOU WHO ARE WAITING ON
THE PHONE LINE MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE TODAY BUT WE
WILL. TAKE SEVENTY FIVE MINUTES
FOR EACH SIDE SO- AS A REMINDER
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
844-291-6364 IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR.
LET ME STRIKE STRIKE THAT THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE ONE
ONE FOUR ZERO. ALL RIGHT LET'S
START WITH SUPPORT WITNESSES ON
THE PHONE LINE MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. EIGHT SIX SIX. THANK
YOU ARE MISTER CARE IF YOU ARE
SUPPORT OF- S. B. EIGHT SIX SIX
UP PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FALL BY
ZERO A. T. T. OPERATOR QUICKLY
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER OFF LINE.
WHICH YOU BACK INTO THE QUEUE.
IN FOR SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT SIX
SIX THE FIRST ONE ZERO POINT
THREE CRISTINA WHO ARE OUT. STEP
WAS OKAY. NINE THREE FIFTEEN.
YOUR LINE IS A- CLOSE BUT AGAIN
WE ARE TAKING A SUPPORT FIRST
OPPOSITION PRESS ZERO D. IF YOU
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AND
THAT'LL TAKE YOURSELF OUT OF THE
QUEUE THANK YOU IT'S A LITTLE
LIKE. NINETY FIVE. WHY NINETY
FIVE YOUR OLYMPIC. I OPPOSE MY
NAME IS CARRIE HAGGERTY AND I
OPPOSE. ALREADY THANK YOU
MODERATOR- IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP
THOSE IN SUPPORT SUPPORT OF S.
B. EIGHT SIX SIX AND THEN AFTER
WE HAVE SUPPORT WE WILL TAKE
THOSE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION. I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND
THAT MISTER CHAIR BUT WE HAD. A
TON OF PEOPLE QUEUE UP BEFORE WE
EVEN STARTED SO I HAVE NO IDEA
IF THEY'RE IN SUPPORT OR- YOU
KNOW. IF THEY'RE NOT SO IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO EVERYBODY ELSE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO TAKE YOURSELF OUT.
OF THE QUEUE IT'LL TELL YOU IF
YOU'RE OUT OF THE QUEUE IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION WE'RE TAKING
SUPPORT ONLY AT THIS TIME.
OVERLYING. FIVE OH NINE. FIVE OH
NINE YOU ARE OPEN. ONE MORE SHOT
FIVE ONE NINE. WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO TWENTY FOUR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TESTIFY PLEASE ON MUTE. I AM
VERY INEFFICIENT AND I COULDN'T
HEAR OUT SO I'LL JUST NEED Q.
WHAT NOW AT ONE ONE THEN BACK IN
YOU GO ASK FOR UP TO THE- THAT
WHAT IT IS. YES. ARE YOU OUT. I
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
CAN LEAVE MY BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE KALO
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
THINK. TWENTY FIVE TWENTY ONE
YOU ARE A FIVE FIFTY ONE SKEWS
ME EUROPEN FIVE FIFTY ONE. HI MY
NAME IS ONE THOUSAND NINE
APPARENT CONCERN WITH COLLISION
BOWLING IN PAPER HERE I PULLED
SB. EIGHT SIX SIX. ONE FOUR
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
FOR SIXTEEN YOU ARE OPEN YES HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME. HELLO WE ARE
YEAH. OKAY GREAT MY NAME IS
CAROLINE I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF A LAY PERSON COMMUNITY OVER
SEVENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE
ARE ABSOLUTELY BE TO FOLLOW OR
BEING AGAINST THIS BILL AND THE
OPPOSING AT THE STATE THROUGH
WASHES US THANK YOU MUCH. FOR
GET THIS ON TRAFFIC ARE IN. OF
THIS BILL KILL BECAUSE TO EVERY
ELSE WILL WAIT TO. OPPOSITE
INTEL MISTER CHAIR OPPOSITE
PROPPED OPPOSITION SO WHITE SIX
OH SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIX OF
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN- I'M STILL
SEVEN I AM OPPOSED BUT I COULD
KNOCK YOU OUT. ALL RIGHT MY-
WE'RE GONNA SWITCH UP HERE- WE
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO-
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION AT THIS POINT SO
LET'S TAKE THE OPPOSITION FIRST
I APOLOGIZE TO THOSE THAT ARE ON
THE PHONE LINE UP IN SUPPORT BUT
WE'RE GONNA START WITH THE
OPPOSITION. SO OPPOSITION TO S.
B. EIGHT SIX SIX YOU'LL GET-
SEVENTY FIVE MINUTES- SO
MODERATOR ONE AGAIN LET'S CUE UP
THE OPPOSITION TO S. B. EIGHT
SIX SIX. OKAY YOU YOU UNDERSTAND
A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE ALREADY
QUEUED UP BEFORE WE EVEN FOR YES
NO I QUESTIONS LET I UNDERSTAND
MODERATOR THAT YOU ARE DOING THE
VERY BEST THAT THE MARKET WE ALL
CANCEL ALL RIGHT THANKS A
MILLION. OKAY OCTOBER LINE SEVEN
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT
TO CENSOR THE. THANK PLEASE
MODERATOR LET'S TO THE NEXT
LEVEL. YEP ONE FIVE TO PLAY GO
AHEAD. EUROPE AT FIVE FIFTY TWO.
HELLO I'M SORRY BECAUSE ME AND
MY NAME IS KAREN FROM MEAN I
ALAMEDA I AM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL AND YOU
GUYS NEED TO HAVE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SHALL BE NEXT PLEASE I FIVE
FOLDER RIDICULOUS NINE ONE THANK
YOU BYE ONE SIX. YOU ARE OF.
MANY WOULD JUST CABRERA CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE PROTECTION OF
THE EDGE. RIGHT TO KID AND I'M
CALLING TO. IT FIFTY EIGHT SIX
SIX THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FIVE ONE OH WAIT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME TERRY KOBE I AM
A CONFLICT OF AND BOARD. AND I
WITH THE AUTHORITY AND ON THE OF
THAT AND MY AS A I STRONG OPPOSE
SB EIGHT SIX SIX THANK YOU MUCH
. PINE ONE TWO PLEASE AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS MARIA AND I'LL POST
BELOW EIGHT SIX SIX ON A MOTHER
OF TWO THANK YOU EARLY CHILDHOOD
THINKING YOU. SIGN TO TWENTY
FOUR YOU OLD. HELLO MY NAME IS
SANDRA MARQUEZ AND I'M A PLASTER
COUNTY RESIDENTS I AM A MOTHER
OF TWO AND I HIGHLY OF THIS
ANSWER ASSEMBLY BILL ALREADY
THANK YOU BUT YEAH THANK YOU.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT YOU ARE
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS A FLOODING
ABOARD USE I AM THE MOTHER OF
THREE UNDER EACH. KID AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B. EIGHT SIX
SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
. VANECK ROLLING ONE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH JANE I'M A LICENSED
REGISTERED NURSE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE FORMALLY OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY I'M A MOTHER OF
FIVE AND I AM VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU. TWENTY
TWO NINETY FOUR EUROPE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO WELL IT. THE CAN BE
A MARINO AM CONSISTENTLY TO AN
OFFENDER WINNER I HIGHLY OPPOSE
SB EIGHT SIX SIX THANK YOU. ONE
ONE TWO AND PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BEING HUMAN STRATA AND MY PEOPLE
GRANDMOTHER AND GREAT
GRANDMOTHER I SUPPOSE THE EIGHT
AND B. EIGHT SIX. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THREE THIRTY TWO YOUR
OFFICE. WHAT FORM PROFIT THE
PHILLIES WITH UNITED THREE THREE
AND ASK OPPOSE AND SEE SIX THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THREE SIXTY NINE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS CAPTAIN MY
BRIDESMAID TOLD LEGISLATOR
ACCOUNTABLE FOR. I REGARDING
THAT SENIOR- YOU TO VOTE NO ON
THE END. SB SIX SIX THANK YOU.
AND WE'LL GO LIVE FOR THIRTEEN
YOU ARE OPEN. FORTY FOUR
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
CALL AND I MUST TAKE A STAND
DOWN BOB AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB EIGHT SIXTY SIX THANK YOU.
FOR TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. MY NAME IS NANCY BOB SCHWARTZ
I AM A GRANDMOTHER OF Q. AND I
OPPOSE S. B. EIGHT SIX SIX.
THANK YOU. TWENTY TWO TEN YOUR
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IN
THE PHOTO RESIDENTS IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY I'M A BACHELOR FOR LEXUS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT
SIX SIX THANK YOU. FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS ROOMY. SEVEN FIVE AND
ARE IN TRONG OPPOSE IF EIGHT SIX
SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOR SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS A
LITTLE MORE FROM AND JUST AND-
RESOLUTE OF PERFECT NINETY AND
TWENTY NINE STRONG BOTH AT THE
SIX SIX THANK YOU. FIVE FORTY
PLEASE AHEAD. I EIGHT SKEWS ME
LIFE FOR EIGHTY PLEASE GO. ON
BEHALF OF MOBILE HEALTH DEFENSE
CALIFORNIA FIFTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS STRONGLY OPPOSE SB EIGHT
SIX SIX THANK YOU. BRING ONE
LINE NOW ONE SEVENTY NINE YOU
ARE OPEN. MY NAME'S ELIZABETH.
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF FOUR MONTHS OVER REACHING
HANDS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF FOUR EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
LUCY NEVER DOLLARS COLORADO.
OKAY REPRESENTING MY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHTY- EIGHT
SIXTY SIX. THANK BY NINETY FIVE
YOU ARE OPEN. NINETY FIVE- I AM
MY NAME IS TERRY HAGGERTY AND
FROM PLASTER COUNTY AND THEY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. FIND EIGHTY PLEASE GO AT
YOUR- YEAH I'M ON. FIVE FOUR
EIGHTY EURO. OUR MOBILE TO ONE
ONE FORTY PLEASE GO. WITH FINE.
HELLO I A MOTHER IN OTHER THAN
HE NEPHEW I STRONGLY OPPOSE ANTI
ON CON BILL THANK YOU. FIVE
THIRTY PLEASE AT. HI THIS IS A
LONG SELF BUT IS FROM BAKER
CALIFORNIA FARMER. OF SIX HOME
HELLO FE ES. THANK YOU. FINE FOR
SEVENTY YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS CAITLYN DAVIS I AM A TEACHER
MOTHER IN CAN YOU ACCOUNT AND I
JUST OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
. FIVE FIVE HUNDRED WE SAW THAT
. HELLO MY NAME IS PAMELA BERET
I'M A MOM INDICATOR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED S. B. EIGHT SIX
SIX. THANK YOU. FIVE ONE OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
NATALIE DAVIS IRON I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. SIXTY EIGHT SIXTY SIX
AND I WONDERED IF I COULD MAKE A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. THIRTY FOUR. THREE
YES. HI MY NAME IS VANESSA GERA
AND- I'M A MOTHER AND AYE
OPPOSED SB EIGHT SIX SIX THANK
YOU. FIVE OH TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THE BALL A LOT. NUMBER THE
NATIONAL DON'T A LOT WORKERS. I
OPPOSE SB. EIGHT THANK YOU. FIVE
EIGHT APPARENTLY. BY THE TIME A
LOT OF YES HELLO MY NAME IS. MY
NAME IS JENNA COLLINS ONE ON.
I'M FROM A MONEY. AND I THAT
MIGHT I WORK WITH MY SON AND I
AM IN OPPOSITION TO BE TO THE
STATE THANK YOU VERY EIGHT SIXTY
SIX THANK YOU BOB. THANK YOU I'M
THREE PLEASE AHEAD. NINETY THREE
YEAR OPEN. ONE MORE SHOT ONE
NINETY THREE. I WILL MOVE ON TO
LINE ONE TWENTY FIVE. WHAT.
TWENTY FIVE. SHE'S GOING TO
DELIGHT OPEN WE CAN HEAR YOU.
EXCELLENT ORAL SEX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. K. NANCY DAVIS I'M THE
MOTHER WITH AN EXECUTIVE THE
FORMER COMMON. I HAVE A FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD LOW YEAR OLD AND A
TENURE OLD. MY MIDDLE DAUGHTER-
WAS BORN A HEART DEFECT AND SHE
IS THANK BE HIGHLY IS YOU THE
MANAGER YOUR YOUR NAME IS. YOUR
PER. OKAY ENACTED THE OPPOSE
THANK THE H. TWO THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ONE TWO OR THREE THE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SUSAN BLACK
IN I'M A MOM OF TWO MACHO AND I
OF TO. THANK YOU. THREE FORTY
SIX YOU ARE ALL. HI MY IDOL RUN
WORRIED THAT AND LET IN PALM CAL
AND A MEMBER OF THE BILL RECALL
BEEN AYE FROM OPPOSE IT YOU
THOUGHT VERY YOUR FOR NAY YOU
VERY MUCH WE WERE. THERE'S
STREAMLINING THREE SAN EIGHT
BECAUSE AHEAD. THREE SO EIGHT
YES WE HEAR OPEN. I WILL MOVE
ALONG THAT LINE NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS LYDIA GERGEN
SMA MOTHERF IN MEMBER OF. WHEN I
HILLS PERRIN'S AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSED BILL THANK YOU A SIX SIX
THANK YOU. FIVE ONE SO SIX
PLEASE CALL. HI MY NAME IS
JENNIFER MAKOWSKI SEPARATE NURSE
IN COUNTY AND I OF OKAY SENATE
BILL GATES SIX SIX. THANK YOU.
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY SIX GO AHEAD
. YEAH. YOU ARE OPEN FOR THIRTY
SIX. FIVE OH NINE GOING. SO WHY
DON'T I HEAR OFTEN. HI MY NAME
IS BONTA SOMETHING DEMOCRATS
COUNTY I AND EIGHT SIX SIX THANK
YOU. AND WE'LL GO TO LIKE. FIVE
NINETEEN. HI MY NAME IS KELLY
MAHONEY. AS SENATOR EGGMAN THE
IMPACT WITHOUT. AND I AM ALSO
THE CHAIRWOMAN AND CO FOUNDER OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY LIBERTY
COALITION AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB EIGHT SIX SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU. SIX SEVEN X. IS FIVE TWENTY
NINE. STE HI MY NAME IS RON I
THINK FOR CAL EVER WELL OVER TEN
FANS. FONG UP AT EIGHT SIX SIX
THANK YOU. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE- THREE NINETY EIGHT. HELLO. ME YES WE CAN. HELLO YES WE
WENT TO THREE DIFFERENT FROM THE
- MY NAME IS MELISSA FRIEDMAN
FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY CALIFORNIA
AND AFTER BLACK. NINE STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FIVE ONE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND TAX ALL
FOUR NUMBER BUT OUT OF MINUTES
SO SIGNIFICANT FOR LEGAL THAT
REPRESENT CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEEN
CORPS ON FULL PROP TO GET BELLY
BUTTON PIERCING AND THANK YOU
FROM THE ARE ANYWHERE THROUGH
OPEN.
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHT SIX SIX
THANK YOU. I THIRTY FIVE EUROPE. FIVE MILLION POSSIBLY LEFT AND
THE MOTHER FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO PROFESSIONAL
THE FIELD OF IMMUNOLOGY I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT SIX
SIX. THANK YOU. BY FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE FORTY
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. JUST ONE
MORE SHOT BY FORTY EIGHT. I WILL
GO TO LINE FOR SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I'M A
KALIAN CHAPTER CHAIR OF MOMS FOR
LIBERTY PLASTER COUNTY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION ALSO THE SISTER OF A
VACCINE INJURED AND HE MAJOR
FROM THE KOBE BAXEEN BROUGHT ON
BY COERCION FROM HIGHER
EDUCATION FACILITIES THANK YOU.
NECKS NECKS RIGHT. BY FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M IN THE
GOLDEN DAWN AND I'M A PARENT AND
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT COERCION
BULLYING AND PEER PRESSURE I
PULLED EIGHT SIX SIX STRONGLY
OPPOSE. MAX I FIFTY THREE YOUR
OPEN. I GOT TO CEMEX. EVERY AND
AN ATTORNEY ON THE MATTER A
MEMBER OF GRANADA HILLS CHARTER
PARENTS UNITED WHOSE CHILDREN
HAD BEEN KICKED OUT OF SCHOOL
FOR REFUSING TO TAKE A COUPLE OF
BAXEEN AND STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
BILL. NEXT ONE MOMENT. NEXT. YES
WE WILL GO TO LINE FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT. ON BEHALF OF CONCERNED
CALIFORNIA PARENTS WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU ZACKS. THANKS WE ARE GOING TO GO TO.
SORRY ONE MOMENT PLEASE THERE WE
GO LINE FOR SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS THERE
ARE NONE ON THE MATTER THE
CHILDREN FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OUT IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE TWENTY THIRD
. THANK YOU THE CLIP THANK YOU
THANKS. FIVE FORTY EIGHT
EUROPEAN. NINE FIVE FORTY EIGHT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFYING IN.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES GO AHEAD
PLEASE. OKAY MY NAME IS TRISH
MINIONS THEY REPRESENT COLTON
JOINT UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
PARENTS UNITED WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB EIGHT SIXTY SIX. THANK
YOU NECKS. FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS LISA
VARGAS I AM THE MOTHER OF A
VACCINE INJURED CHILD I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB EIGHT COOKBOOKS THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT. FORTY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME
. SO I CAN GO AHEAD AND HANDLE
YES MY NAME IS WRITTEN CRITICAL
MILLION FAN I'M A PARENT OF
THREE CHILDREN AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
BILL. MAX BY FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
KATHERINE ROGERS I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF LET THEM LEARN OAKDALE
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU NEXT. BY SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ROBIN
THE GARY AND I GO TO CALVARY
CHAPEL CHINO HILLS CHURCH I AM
AN AMBASSADOR FOR JESUS CHRIST
AND I OPPOSE WITH DEMONIC BILL
THANK YOU NEXT. WE WILL GO TO
FIVE SIXTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY BY
SIXTY FOUR. I WILL ALISON LERI
HELLO THANK YOU L. SAID. HI MY
NAME IS ALLISON LEE I'M A
STUDENT AND A MEMBER PROTECT US
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. WHAT DO IN OPPOSITION BUT
THAT EVEN STUFF TO. GO AHEAD
NEXT. ONE THREE SIXTY ARE OPEN.
YEAH HI- GABRIELLE OKAY BRAWL
WITH EAST WHITTIER PARENTS
UNITED AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AT
EIGHT SIX SIX. THANK YOU NEXT.
BY THE WAY PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
THE WAY YOUR LINE IS OPEN- YES
HELLO MY NAME IS NICOLE NOW BEEN
FROM MANHATTAN BEACH CALIFORNIA
I'M A MOTHER OF TWO OF THE
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB EIGHT. EXPECTS THANK
YOU NEXT FIVE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ALPINIST METER
REPRESENTING CHEN UP OF
REPRESENTING OVER FOUR THOUSAND
ST PETER'S ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND
PROBABLY YOU THAT HOWARD AND I
AM STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL. SIX
FOR EIGHTY SEVEN YEAR OLD. FOX
ROAD HE STRONGLY OPPOSED. NEXT
FIVE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI MY NAME IS JOHN LENNON I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHT SIX SIX.
THANK YOU NEXT. ONE SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL
WE'LL MOVE ON A LINE THAT TO
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS DESIREE BRADY I'M A
PARENT AND VOLUNTEER WITH
CALIFORNIA FREEDOM KEEPERS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
NEXT. ONE THIRTY FIVE EUROPEAN.
HI MY NAME IS IAN JAMIESON CO
FOUNDER OF LOS ANGELES TWO
SITUATION UNITY YOU PEOPLE ARE
CHILD ABUSING TOTALITARIAN TO
KNOWN AS BE EIGHT SIX SIX THANK
YOU MAX. ONE SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY OKAY I WAS
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
WE HEAR YOU. HI THERE MY NAME IS
DINO MARTENS AND THE MOTHER OF
THE BACKING AND YOUR CHILD I
REPRESENTING MY FAMILY AND ABC
UNIFIED PARENTS FOR CHOICE AND
FREEDOM. AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT. FOUR
THIRTY TWO YEAR OPEN. IN OAKLAND
I WITH TEAMS CONCERNED ABOUT
COERCION BILLING IN PROGRESSION
AYE OPPOSED SB EIGHT SIX SIX
THANK YOU NEXT. WHAT TWO YEAR
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS CHRIS JONES
I'M AFFILIATED WITH LET THEM
CHOOSE ANOTHER FROM ORANGE
COUNTY I WOULD LIKE T THANK YOU
FOR SHARING ALL OF US IN STRONG
OPPOSITION AT EIGHT SIX SIX
YOU'RE WELCOME NEXT. FOUR FIFTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR SIXTY
TWO WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY.
HI MY NAME IS MELISSA FORD I AM
A MOM OF TWO AND PLASTER COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT
SIX SIX THANK YOU THE EX. AND IT
WILL LITTLE LINE ONE MOMENT. WHY
NOT FOR SIXTY TWO YOUR OPEN.
USING WATER LINE- FIVE TWENTY
SIX. HI MY NAME IS LAURA FRAZIER
I'M A CONSTITUENT OF HENRY STERN
I'M CALLING TO OPPOSE THE STYLE
MINORS CANNOT INTENT THANK YOU.
BY TWENTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. ON
THE CONSERVE OUR QUEUE LINE FIVE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS SHERRY AND MARINO MY
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND IPHONE
SB EIGHT SIX SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SIX OH ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN
I'M AN EDUCATOR AND MOTHER OF
THREE AND NINE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION AT EIGHT EIGHT SIX
SIX. THANK YOU. SIX OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. L. A. RIVER
MALL FROM MONTEREY COUNTY
REPRESENTING SCHOOL AGE PARENTS
IN CARMEL UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
S. B. EIGHT SIX SIX. THANK YOU.
WE WILL ALIGN SIX OH FOUR.
EXCUSE ME BY IN- SIX OF SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHAU COCKER
PARA FROM SENATOR EARLIER TO
DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THE PILOT MONTANA EXCUSE
LINE AT SIX TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS FOR ABOUT
THE HOLES I'M DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA PARENT UNION
CALIFORNIA POLICY CENTER AND WE
URGE YOU TO STOP FOLLOWING THE
MONEY AND OPPOSE THANK YOU EIGHT
SIX SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BY
NINETY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE MORE SHOT NINETY SEVEN. ONE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
FORTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN. WE CAN
HEAR YOU ON FORTY ONE. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL TRY ONE ONE NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CALIBRATE PLANO FIVE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DEREK AND I A MOTHER OF I THINK
OF RIGHTS AND I ASKED AT EIGHT
EIGHT SIX SIX. THANK YOU. BYE
BYE NINETY FOR YOUR OPEN. BUT
WHAT I REPRESENT THOUSANDS OF
PARENTS BENDER KNOCKOFF FREEDOM
ALLIANCE AND THE MOTHER OF A
BACKING AND YOUR CHILD AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT
EXPECT. THANK YOU. I THREE SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS MONIQUE AND I'M CALLING FROM
WITH YOUR PARENTS FOR CHOICE AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THREE NINETY SEVEN
YOU ARE HOPING. HI MY NAME IS
MICHELLE SHEKEL FUND CANNOT I'M
A MOM AND I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SIX FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS KNOWLEDGE YOU CAN TO REGISTER
TO FIFTEEN YEARS AND MOTHER I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL MINOR
CANNOT CONSENT TO RISKY MEDICAL
PROCEDURES THANK YOU HAVE A
GREAT DAY THANK YOU. THE SIX
FOURTEEN YOUR OPEN. HIS
KNOWLEDGE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS NOW TO CAN COVERAGES NURSES
YEARS IN MOTHER MINORS CANNOT-
CENTERING YOU MEDICAL ARE
CLOSELY SIX SIX SO THANK YOU FOR
CHOOSING YOURSELF MODERN JUST TO
UP FOR THOSE WHO ARE LISTENING
SO- AS I MENTIONED THE SEVENTY
FIVE MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT THOSE THAT ARE
CALLING IN- GO BEYOND THEIR NAME
THEIR AFFILIATION IN THEIR
POSITION WHAT THAT DOES IS IT
TAKES IT ME IT MEANS THAT OTHERS
WON'T BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY VOICE
THEIR VIEW. SO GO HEAD MODERATOR
NEXT. ALL RIGHT. WE WILL GO TO
LINE SIX SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HELLO MY NAME IS MARIE TO THE
CARIA I'M AN EDUCATOR THE MOTHER
OF A DAUGHTER WITH THE AUTO
IMMUNE DISEASE AND REPRESENTING
LA CAPTOR AT CATHOLIC FAMILIES
FOR FREEDOM AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE ITSELF. THANK YOU. WHY TO
FORTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS KAREN OF CAMPARI
MEMBER OF BAY AREA FREEDOM
ALLIANCE ON THE HEAD OF THE-
COMMITTEE AGAINST THE TEN BAD
BILLS AND NOT STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. TWENTY THREE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AT. MY NAME'S
CHRIS MARILYN IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. BY FIFTEEN YOU ARE
OPEN. I HOPE I DIDN'T SORRY HI
MY NAME IS THAT THE GOVERNMENT
OFF I'M A MOTHER OF THREE OF
COLUSA COUNTY AND I WOULD LIKE
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. SIX FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN THIRD FATHER I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. AND WE WERE SIX EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
BRIAN- I'M PART OF THE
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL OF SAVE OUR
CINEMA AND THE SUBGROUP HILTON
PHYSICIANS ARE PARENTS NOT THE
STATE AND WE IN DURING HIGHLY
OPPOSE. SIX EIGHT SIXTY SIX.
THANK YOU ELEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS MONICA HODGE AND
ANOTHER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. FOUR SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND BRING IN THE CAR FROM
THE CAR COMPLETED- CALIFORNIA
BEFORE MADE PUBLIC SCHOOL
EDUCATOR REPRESENTING MY PRIVATE
HOPEFULLY COMMUNITY SOME FROM
THE INCIDENT FIRE THE BILL OVER
EACH OF THE PRINTER RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF THE NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU HERE WE WILL
NOT ONLY IS THE LINE TO NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS MELISSA WHAT WITH STAND
UP READY COUNTY AND I A MOTHER
I. OPPOSE AT THE EXPECT THANK
YOU THANK YOU EXT. TWENTY TWO.
FIVE SIX TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD HI. HI MY NAME IS THE
THEIR ABILITY ON I AM AN
EDUCATOR AN AMBASSADOR FOR
ACCENT REPRESENTING THE LATINO
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT
EXCEPT. THANK YOU. SIX FORTY
THREE YOUR OPEN. HELP YOU
DISTRICT MY MOTHER IN AN EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS THAT WANT TO
KEEP MY PARENTAL RIGHTS I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SIX SIX THANK
YOU. THREE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ELAINE
FROM UP AND REPRESENTING A PLAN
PERRANCE FOR CHANGE AND FREEDOM
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B.
EIGHT SIX SIX. THANK YOU. OR
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD- MY
NAME IT'S ALL ALL ON YOUR WILL
BE DONE BY THE DOCTOR IT'S ON
AND TRONG BELIEF CLOSE IT FAILS
. THANK YOU. FOUR SEVENTY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. FOR SEVENTY FOUR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY. SIX
NINETEEN- THAT. I AM FAIR AND
MOTHERS AND EDUCATOR AND I
OPPOSE THANK YOU THE ACCESS SIX
TWENTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS EVA HORN REPRESENTING
PLASTER COUNTY PARENTS FOR
CHOICE AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SIX THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HELLO MY NAME IS AN K. OF
SACRAMENTO I'M A MOTHER OF THREE
SONS AND A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE WITH THE FOR FREEDOM I
OPPOSE SB EIGHT X. X. THANK YOU
. TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE YOU
ARE OPEN. FOR TWENTY FIVE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY. YEAH THANK
YOU- MY NAME IS JANA I'M CALLING
FROM GRANADA HILLS CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AT EIGHT SIX SIX
DIRECTLY TO LOSE IT ALL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE- FIVE NINETY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINETY FIVE. I WILL
MOVE ON TO FIVE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO HELLO YES
GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY MAKE UP BRUNO
CARMEL UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
MONTEREY COUNTY CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL AND I
HOPE GOD FORGIVES YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. EXACTLY AND NEXT GO
TO LINE THREE NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIVE HELLO- QUESTION
WHAT THIS DECEMBER TO DINO
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU. SIX
FORTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. MY NAME
IS TERRA I'M A NURSE AND MOTHER
AND FOUNDER OF HOLDOVERS FOR
FREEDOM AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. SIX FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
HEARING FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY
MOTHER AND GRANDMOTHER IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. SIX FIFTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS LORRAINE AND MICHAEL'S
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
PARENTS UNITED AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHT SIX SIX. THANK YOU
. SIX SIX YOU ARE OPEN- CHOCOLAT
AND I REFERRED ALL THE PARENTS
HERE. WE ARE ALL STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO PROLONGING IN KEEPING
ALREADY THANK YOU WIENER IN ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. HIS BROTHER. SO
WE ARE REALLY DOWN HERE I'M JUST
JUST SO THOSE ON THE PHONE NOW-
WE'VE GONE THIRTY MINUTES IT
WITH THOSE IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE THAT MEANS THERE'S ANOTHER
FORTY FIVE MINUTES-
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE MANY MORE
ON THE PHONE THEN WILL BE
ACCOMMODATED NEXT FORTY FIVE
MINUTES- GO HEAD MODERATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WILL GO
OVER THE LINE- SIX SEVENTY TWO
YOUR OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ERIK
KELLY FLORES I REPRESENT SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY LIBERTY COALITION
AND CATHOLIC FAMILIES FOR
FREEDOM PLEASE STOP THE ATTACK
ON OUR CHILDREN THANK YOU
FINALLY OPPOSE ARAMBULA THANK
YOU. SIX FIFTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN
. HI COME MORNING- MY NAME IS
RANDY HOAGLAND- MOTHER OF A
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD- COUNTY AND
FACE FROM THE OPPOSE FIFTY EIGHT
SIX ALL RIGHTY. FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS SANDEEP ARRIVE I AM A MOTHER
OF Q. I AM ALSO A MEMBER AND
STAND FOR FREEDOM GROUP OF ALLEY
I AM ALSO A VACCINE INJURED FROM
THE FIVE HER VACCINE YOU
PROBABLY OPPOSE THIS BILL OKAY.
I MEAN FOR SIXTY SEVEN YOU ARE
OKAY. YES MY NAME IS MERRY BELL
GARCIA I DIDN'T GRANADA HILLS
AND I'LL PULL THIS. I'M ALSO A
PERSON THAT FIGHT FOR LUCKY
ALREADY THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIX
POINT WHERE PROJECTS. IT FIVE
SIX FIFTY THREE ARE OLD. HI MY
NAME IS ROMERO I AM FROM COUNTY
AND MOTHER THE BEAUTIFUL CHIU
AND I. OPPOSE NEXT. SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT. SOUNDER LEGISLATORS CLASS
HAD A FILE THAT YOUR KIDS DON'T
DARE TOUCH OUR KIDS HAD A FIVE
HE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. HEY NO I
NEED FROM SAN DIEGO I AM WITH
BLACK THERE TRAVEL. ORGANIZED
HERE REPRESENTING PARENTS AND
AMERICA THAT YOU THAT FREEDOM
THERE'S NOWHERE ELSE THANK YOU.
FIVE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI YES MY NAME IS MARGARET A
RAIDER I AM A MOTHER WHO LIVES
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I'M
CALLING IN OPPOSITION BECAUSE I
AM THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. SIX FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL ONE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR. WE'LL GO FOR TRY SIX
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA MCKINNEY I AM
A NURSE IN SAN BERNADINO AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTIES AND I OPPOSE
EIGHT SIX SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU. SIX NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I MANY K. PRINCESS I AM A
MOTHER FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AT HE SAID THANK
YOU THANK YOU. SEVEN OH EIGHT
YOU ARE OFTEN. FIVE MILLION
SEVENTY FIVE I AM THE MOTHER AND
A FRIEND AND FIRMLY OPPOSE IT
FOR THAT THANK YOU. SEVEN SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MATT. ONE-
GRANDPARENT OF A AND NOW A. U.
S. M. AND UP TO BILL THANK YOU.
FIND SEVEN TWENTY SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. YES HI GOLWALKAR TO
FORTIFY CAL. I'M OF THE BACK IN
CHILD I STRONG OPPOSE SB EIGHT
FIFTY THANK YOU. BUILDING ALONG
WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVEN THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA I'M FROM CHESHIRE
COUNTY I'M A PARENT OF A VACCINE
INJURED TEENAGER WHO AFTER FIVE
YEARS ISN'T STILL IN PAIN EVERY
MOMENT OF HER LIFE I FROM THE
UNCLE. THE YOU. FOUR FIFTY YOU
ARE OPEN. RIGHT MILLION SWIMMING
AND ON BEHALF OF S. STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB EIGHT SIX SIX. THANK
YOU. SEVEN THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SANTA CLARA MATCH FROM
PLASTER COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB EIGHT SIX SIX MINORS
ARE UNABLE TO CONSENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. SEVEN FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ARE YOU
LEVELS FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY AND-
NUMBER OF PHYSICIANS AND
PATIENTS THREE CLEANING
MEDICINES STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
EIGHT SIX SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. RIGHT IS ALL THE SEVEN
FIFTY TWO. HI MY NAME IS MAX
WILLIAM A TEENAGER WITH REBUILD
CALIFORNIA THAT'S REBUILD
CALIFORNIA .COM AND I'M IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU STE
THANK YOU. FIVE SEVEN SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR FOUR ONE
ON BEHALF- AGENCIES AND ALSO MY
ARMENIAN FOOD FROM MY PAL SANTA
CLARA IN FLATHEAD COUNTY IN
STRUGGLE PROVISIONS THANK YOU.
SEVEN SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. AND WE THOUGHT I'M TURN AND
MOTHER THREE COUNTY SENATORS
PLEASE LISTEN THE GARDEN YOUR
COLLEGE AND NO ON THANK YOU
WOMAN FROM OPPOSITE. ALREADY
THANK YOU SEVENTY SIX YOU ARE
SEVEN SEVENTY SIX. IN ORDER TO
CARRY TO AND I HAVE OF BILL
THANK YOU. BURKE FIFTY THREE OR
OPEN. HI THERE THIS IS JOHN I'M
A MOTHER OF THREE AND LOVER AND
THE FAMILY AND I STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSES THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME OUR
REPORTER BY I'M REPRESENTING
TAKESTAN ASCALON AND A MOTHER OF
FOUR I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT
SIX SIX THANK YOU- THANK YOU.
SEVENTY I DON'T HAVE BEEN ALISON
I'M FROM SANTA BARBARA COUNTY- I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I THOUGHT
YOUR SPEC THE RIGHT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE ONLY MARTIN
A TRUCKER- PREPARED I SEE MOVING
BOB POSE THANK YOU. SEVEN NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK MY
NAME IS JULIA GRAHAM ON MY
MOTHER AND SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AND AYE OPPOSED THE BILL HE
EXPECTS. THANK YOU. I'M NOT
MOVING ALONG WITH YOUR CARE WILL
TRY LINE- IT- TO YOUR OPEN. I AM
SURE MCEWING HARPER OF THE
PEOPLE'S MOVEMENT CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I TRY SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY SEVENTY
ONE YEAR OLD BUT- IT'S. I'M MORE
SHOCKED BY SEVENTY ONE. THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ANDREA REYNOLDS TWENTY
HAVE A GRIN HILLS CHARTER HILLS
UNITED WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
EIGHT SIX SIX FIRE BRAINPOWER
AND IMPLEMENTERS THANK YOU. SIX
EIGHT NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
SHE HAD AN OFTEN ORDER OF GAS
STANISLAUS FOR THE MOTHER OF
THREE AND I STRONGLY OF THE-
THANK YOU. FOUR THIRTY SIX CALL
AT. FOUR THIRTY SIX. GARY OF.
LET'S GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
GO TO LINE SIX HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CARLA ON
THE LAWN I AM REPRESENTING STORM
HERE IN SAN DIEGO I'M A MOTHER
OF FOUR DAUGHTERS AND I AM
SUPPOSED TO LEAVE FOR. FIVE THIS
MEASURE HE- S. B. EIGHT SIX.
THANK YOU SIX FOUR THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR THIRTY
THREE WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY. THE LINE WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
THIRTY THREE. HI A CHRISTIE FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE S. B.
EIGHT SIX SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU. SIX SIXTY SEVEN YOU ARE
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING I'M CARE
ITEMS FROM STANDARD ONE CARAMEL
CLAIRE AND ALL HONESTY PARENTS
AGAINST MANDATE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE ACT HE EXPECTS. SIX SIXTY
SIX OUR SKEWS THE SIX ARE SIX
NINETY ONE WILL TRY GO AHEAD SIX
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
REFERRAL PROCEDURES SACRAMENTO
SENATOR PANIC MY SENATOR I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. SEVEN OH THREE YOUR OPEN.
SHOULD BE HIGHER POTENTIAL
ACCOUNTING I AM A MOTHER OF HILL
I'M A POSTPARTUM DOULA AND I AM
A MEMBER OF FAITH BAPTIST CHURCH
AND SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
. THANK YOU. SEVEN THIRTY ONE
YEAR OPEN. HELLO HEATHER KELLER
SACRAMENTO COUNTY RESIDENTS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
SEVEN SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI MY NAME'S VICTORIA GARCIA
EAGLE COUNTY AND CHRONIC
CONDITIONS AS BEING FIXED. THANK
YOU. EIGHT OH THREE PLEASE CALL
AT. HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL DINAH
AND THAT OUR A AND BELIEVE HIM
WITH MUHAMMAD. FREEDOM IN ALSO
ON EAGLES AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS ON A MOTHER CHILDREN. THANK
YOU. IT ALL FOR YOU ARE OPEN. HI
THIS IS RENEE ROGERS CALLING
FROM CALIFORNIA PARENTS UNITED
WE OPPOSE WELL YOU GUYS NEED A
RING AROUND THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE. EIGHT SIXTY
EXCUSE ME FOR SIXTY THREE FOUR
SIXTY THREE YOUR OPEN. YES VERY
METHODICAL AMERICANS ORANGE
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THEMSELVES THANK YOU. EIGHT
HUNDRED AND EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
FARLEY I'M FROM LOS ANGELES I'M
A MOTHER I'M A SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST AND THE CO FOUNDER
OF LOS ANGELES EDUCATORS AND
PARENTS UNITED I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB EIGHT SIX SIX THANK
YOU. EIGHT TWELVE YOU ARE OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS JACQUELINE ROARS
FROM NAPA AND THE REGISTERED
NURSE MOTHER OF FOUR WE KEEP
ACTING INJURED CHILDREN I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT SIX
SIX THANK YOU. EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
FIFTY. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN BLOW. OKAY HI MY NAME IS
TURNING FIFTY I'M CALLING FROM
HAYWARD CALIFORNIA I AM A MOTHER
OF THREE PRECIOUS CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU. IT ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOUR TO TESTIFY. SEVEN
THIRTY NINE. WILL MOVE ALONG
YEAH LATE TERM HELLO WE'RE HERE
HELLO YES GO AHEAD NEAR ME YES
WE CAN. M. OKAY MY NAME IS
COURTNEY AND I AND REPRESENTS
CIRCLING MOMENTS AND- THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF PARENTS ON
AROUND THE WORLD AND DO WE
OPPOSE SB EIGHT SIX SIX THANK
YOU. FIVE NINETY ONE EUROPE. IN
ORDER TO PUBLIC OPPORTUNITIES
AHEAD OF THREE AND IT'S ONLY DO
NOT PURPORT BILL OF. THANK YOU.
EIGHT ELEVEN CALL. MY NAME IS
THE HEARING DOWN FOR AND TAX
COUNTY AND MY MOTHER OF TWO AT
THE RESPECT THE RIGHTS OF
SCIENCEAND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB EIGHT SIX SIX. THANK YOU.
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWENTY FOUR. I WILL TRY
EIGHT TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
OR DO YOU WANT TO FIGHT TWENTY
FOUR GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
ALLEY. THANK YOU GO AHEAD. BY
NAY TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS NICOLE I THE ONE
I'M CALLING FROM CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE S.
B. EIGHT SIX SIX. THANK YOU.
EIGHT FORTY YOU ARE OPEN. EIGHT
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE'LL TRY
EIGHT SEVEN BUT- HI MY NAME IS.
MY MOTHER YOU AND UNDOCUMENTED
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
ITSELF. THANK YOU. EIGHT SEVENTY
YOUR OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS VERONICA FIVE TIMELY SENATE
STAMINA DINO COUNTY AND A MOTHER
OF FOUR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB EIGHT SIX SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU. SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
WELL YES YES GO AHEAD HELLO MY
FUND CALLAHAN MOTHER OF A
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL CONSTITUENTS
LEFT WEALTHY PEOPLE OUT. NINETY
SEVEN SIXTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
SEVEN SIX ONE. HELLO MY NAME IS
JASMINE I AM FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. SEVEN SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE WILL TRY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE. DO YOU WANT TO
TESTIFY SOME OF THE SIXTY FIVE
ONE MORE CHANCE. WILL MOVE TO
SEVEN EIGHTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
SEVEN EIGHTY ONE ELEVEN YES GO
AHEAD. WITH OVER THIRTY NO
MANDATES WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY ON
CALLING FROM CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
AND HE STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK
YOU. EIGHT SEVENTY NINE YOU ARE
OPEN. THIS IS GREAT I REPRESENT
BARN UNDERGROUND THE MEADOW VIEW
LEARNING CENTER AND I'M A MOM OF
THREE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
STOCK. THANK YOU. THREE FIFTY
TWO PLEASE CONTACT. HI MY NAME
IS LINDA SCHWARTZ I AM A
CONCERNED MOTHER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB EIGHT SIX SIX. THANK
YOU YEAH. EIGHT SEVENTEEN YOUR
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS YOUR NAME
SIR I'M FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE AT THE EIGHT SIX SIX
THANK YOU HAVE A GOOD DAY. THANK
YOU. EIGHT SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT SEVENTY SIX WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TESTIFY. ONE MORE SHOT A
SEVENTY SIX YEAR OPEN WE CAN
HEAR YOU. TRYLINE EIGHT EIGHTY
TWO YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTOPHER AND MEN ON FROM SAN
MATTEO COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE S. B. EIGHT SIXTY SIX
ALREADY THANK YOU. FIVE ONE
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
KERRY EDWARDS AND THE MOTHER IN
CAMBODIA COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB EIGHT EXPECT. THANK
YOU. WE WILL GO TO LINE EIGHT
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS A NEW SCARBOROUGH CAME
MOTHER OF TWO LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND STRICTLY IN A POSITION OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT SIX SIX. THANK
YOU. BY EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT YOU
ARE OPEN. HI THANK YOU MY NAME
IS LAURIE CENA I REPRESENT SAVE
OUR NORMAN IN THE NORFOLK COUNTY
CALIFORNIA MANY RESIDENTS FROM
MULTI GENERATIONAL FAMILIES HAVE
BEEN HERE FOR YEARS THE FOR
STUDENTS INCLUDING OURSELVES
GOING THROUGH THE SCHOOL SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE IT
STRONGLY EIGHT SIX SIX O'CLOCK
ABOUT. THANK YOU. FULL TRYLINE
NINE. NINE ELEVEN NINE ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CASSANDRA GONNA STANISLAUS
COUNTY RESIDENT MOTHER OF THREE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT
SIX SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE NINE TWENTY ONE YOU ARE
OPEN. SO EVERY YES HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES- BROWN CALLING FROM
SENATOR WITH HELP HE SAID STRICT
- AND I JUST WANT TO ASK YOU
GUYS TO MAKE SURE WE KEEP OUR
PARENTAL RIGHTS AND I OPPOSE IT
HE EXPECTS ALREADY THANK YOU TO.
THANK YOU. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE. THANK FOURTEEN YOU ARE
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JULIE FIELD
AND I'M FROM SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE S. B. EIGHT
SIX SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. XEROX I TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
THE BRAND'S OF FATAL. THERE ARE
THREE CONSERVE MEMBERSHIP ON
FREEDOM COALITION AND I OPPOSE
SB SIX THANK YOU. BY TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIX BY TWENTY
FOUR YEAR OLD. WHAT MORE SHOT AT
NINE TWENTY FOUR. WE WILL TRY
LINE NINE THIRTY EIGHT. HI MY
NAME IS SAMANTHA MARCHAND PAY
CALLING FROM KING COUNTY MATTER
IF YOU AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
EIGHT SIX SIX. NINE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GUESS MY NAME
IS BRIANNA PRINT HIM FROM L. A.
COUNTY- MOTHER OF FOUR AND I
OPPOSE. NINE TWENTY FIVE YOU ARE
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS REFER TO
WIDEN THE GRANDMOTHER OF FEET
AND I AM CONCERNED MADERA COUNTY
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK. HE
THANK YOU. THANK FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE FORTY SIX
YOU ARE OPEN- HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME WE CAN. OKAY MY NAME IS
JACQUELINE AND I LIVE IN PLASTER
COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND I AM
APPEARANCE AND HOPE TO BE A
GRANDPARENT ONE DAY. AND I THAT
I HAVE ONE QUESTION. THANK YOU
THE NEXT PLEASE HOLD. BY NINE
FORTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. I'M
NATALIE POTTER POTTER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT SIX
THANK YOU. FIVE SIX NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
BY YEAH I'M DONE I'M CALLING
FROM WEST COVINA. AND I'M WITH
THE GROUP WITH WHAT CLOTHING OF
PARENTS WERE CHOI AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. FIVE TWENTY. GO AHEAD. A
TWENTY SEVEN YEAR OPEN. DO IT
TESTIFIED I TWENTY SEVEN HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN. HI THIS
IS- R. J. STEWART TO RICHARD TO
STEWART AND BY OPPOSED FIFTY
THANKS FOR THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
TEAM PLAYS KIND SEVEN ARE ALSO.
YES HI MY NAME IS LAURA GARCIA
BUT IT LA AND I'M CALLING TO.
SEE WHETHER. CALLING PROTEIN SB. THANK YOU. SIXTY THREE YOUR
OFFICE NINE SIXTY THREE. HI MY
NAME IS XIAO THE MY GRANDMOTHER
HERE AND A MEMBER OF THE PUMP
FREEDOM CALL AND I SURE OPPOSE
THE CELL THANK YOU. FOUR THREE
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALL HAVE
TULARE COUNTY SEAT. THEY OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANKS SIXTY
SIX YOUR OPEN. WOW EILEEN PAUL
OR BLACK CALIFORNIANS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU
. OR SEVENTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TESTIFY. BUT MORE SHOT
FOR SEVENTY SEVEN. WORLDWIDE FOR
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHERE THIRTY THREE. YOU ARE OPEN
FOR THIRTY THREE. EIGHT THIRTY
PRESS ONE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WE'LL TRY- ONE EIGHT EIGHT SIXTY
EIGHT. HI CHRISTINA CALDERON I
AM A FAN OF AUTHOR RATHER MOTHER
YOU AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHT
SIX SIX THANK YOU. SEVEN SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT SEVEN SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE CAN
HEAR YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOB
MOVING ALONG OVERNIGHT. SEVENTY
THREE EUROPA NINETY SEVENTY
THREE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MARTIN APOLLO TANO I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE PUMP BILL
FREEDOM COALITION I AM A FATHER
AND I STRONGLY. CLOSE EIGHT
SIXTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK
SEVENTY SEVEN YOU'RE OPEN. WE
HAVE FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE
WILL ALIGN SIX FIFTY. DEFINITELY. HELLO YEAH YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
. OKAY MY NAME IS SUSAN GRIFFITH
THE MATERIA CONSISTS FREEDOM A
MOTHER AND A FORMER TEENAGER AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SLIPPERY
SLOPE ALL RIGHTY THANK YOU.
STRUCTURE CAN YOU GIVE ME ABOUT
FIVE SECONDS HERE TO CLEAR
SCREEN OR JUST IT'S A LITTLE
OVER ONE THOSE TAKE A MINUTE ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. OKAY SECOND
PLEASE. ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY
MUCH- PLEASE DONATE ONE ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ASK APPOSITION- AT
THE EIGHT SIX SIX WE'LL GO TO
LINE I FORTY FOURTH. THANK THANK
FORTY TO YOUR. BUT WE'LL TRY ONE
EIGHT NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. AND WE'RE BACK TO ROCK HELLO
THIS IS PERFECT ARRIVED FROM
NORFOLK COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA I
REPRESENTS FAVORED THE NOW MY
REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF
PARENTS HERE WHO ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED U. S. B. EIGHT SEVEN.
EIGHT SIXTY SIX. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YEAH YES WELL WE HAVE WE HEARD
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT.
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. YES YES GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME
AND NUMBER AND I AM A PARENT AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL. THANK
YOU. AN OLD PHOTO I SEVEN TWENTY
YOU ARE OPEN. SEVEN TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORE SHOT.
SEVEN TWENTY. WE WILL TRY LINE.
SIXTY FOUR.
TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS MARGARET WOULD
WORK FROM VENTURA COUNTY
CALIFORNIA I'M A MOTHER
OFFICIATING FOR HIM AND OTHER
STUDENTS IN OUR COUNTY AND STATE
THANKS STRONGLY OPPOSED. THANK
YOU. SIX EIGHTY FOR YOUR OPEN.
HELLO WE'LL TRY WHY NINE SEVEN
TWENTY.
I SEVEN TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALL WITH. GREAT LINE
EIGHT OH SIX YOUR OPEN. A NATO
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT WILL TRY
TO EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE.
YEAH ARE YOU NEXT. OKAY TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE SEVENTY ONE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TESTIFY. ALL WE'LL TRY
LIKE SEVEN THIRTY TWO. STE BY
ONE EIGHTY WE'LL TRY YOU FIXED.
ALREADY NEXT. THANK. HELLO THIS
YEAR HERE. WHAT EXTENT LINE.
NINE FIFTY.
ALREADY NEXT. YEAH I GIVE US
JUST A MOMENT HERE WITH STREET
IN THE SOUTH HERE.
YUP COUNTY RIVERSIDE LINE NINE
NINETEEN. Q.
ALREADY HAVE MODERATE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE. THERE ARE PLEASE
GIVE US A MOMENT HERE WE'RE
TRYING TO REFRESH THE SCREEN THE
SCREEN HERE.
BACK TO HAPPEN RIGHT. I'LL BE
TRY OVER AGAIN I THINK THERE.
SYSTEM HIT THE WALL HERE LATE
SEVEN THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
SEVEN THIRTY TWO. BY SEVEN
THIRTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN.
RESEARCHERS ARE YOU STILL THERE
IS. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU QUITE
CLEARLY OKAY. THANK YOU WHAT
CRY- ONE EIGHT SEVEN THIRTY TWO
YEAR OPEN. WE CAN AREA OKAY
ORDER TRY ONE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONE EIGHTY. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN'T. OKAY MY NAME
IS DEANNA LARSON I'M CALLING
FROM RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. YOU KNOW
YOU'RE DISGUSTING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT PLEASE. BY ONE
THOUSAND FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I CAN TELL I AM A LIFELONG
DEMOCRAT AND A LATINA MOM OF TWO
AND I AM CALLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL I HAVE A
VACCINE INJURED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. PLEASE X. WE WILL VOTE.
LINE NINE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT THE **** COOL NINETEEN
HAVE NINE DON'T THINK. ALL RIGHT
HERE AND- OKAY THANK YOU. WHY
TEN TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY IS
KATHY MAN I'M FROM WINTER AND
THE GRANDMOTHER OF FIVE
IMPRESSIONABLE CHILDREN AND A
MEMBER OF NUMBER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
. I TEN TWENTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MIDDLE AND IF IT'S
HAPPENING I'M AN EDUCATOR AT
HEARING OF THREE AND A MEMBER AT
NUST FOR FREEDOM AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB EIGHT SIX SIX THANK
YOU. AND NEXT TO SLIDE TEN
TWENTY SIX YOUR OPEN.
INSTITUTIONAL WILL PERSONAL
TRAINER OF A POLITICAL SORRY
FEARING HER MENTOR SORRY NO B.
S. ARE STRONG OPPOSED SB SIX X.
THANK YOU. HELLO THIS ORDER TRY
ANSWER LIKE FIFTY FOUR AT STE.
WHAT A FIFTY FIFTY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO SEARCH FOR YOUR WE CAN
HEAR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. R. EIGHT
TEN TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHAU JONES REPRESENTING TEN
THOUSAND FAMILIES FOR CATHOLIC
FAMILIES FOR FREEDOM STRONGLY
OPPOSE GET YOUR HANDS OFF MY
CHILDREN THANK YOU. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE TEN FORTY FIVE TEN
FORTY FIVE YEAR OPEN. HELLO. CAN
YOU HEAR WE CAN HEAR YOU GO HEAD
. HI MY NAME IS THE MOON YO'S
COMING FROM WORKING COUNTY
REPRESENTING ABOUT HOW PARENTS
CHOI. WRONGLY OPPOSED RADICAL
BILL ALREADY THANK YOU BRANCH
RIGHT ALL RIGHT NEXT. SEVENTY
FOUR YEAR OPEN. SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE CAN HEAR YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'LL TRY SEVEN
THIRTY FIVE YEAR OLD THING. HI
MONICA LAWS ORANGE COUNTY AND I
AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION SB EIGHT
SIX SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE YEAR OLD BUT GO
AHEAD. SEVEN FIFTY FIVE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES OUR IN BRITAIN I'M
CALLING FROM ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OUR
UNIFIED PARENTS UNITED. STRONG
OPPOSITION OF A MOTHER OF TWO
AND HAVING A VACCINE INJURED
NEXT YEAR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
TEN THIRTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
HELLO DURING THE SPRING. YOU
FIFTY PROGRAM. YES PLEASE. TEN
FIFTY EIGHT YEAR OLD BUT. FIFTY
EIGHT WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY
. LAST YEAR. YES WE CAN CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN I WANT TO THE
OR R. HI ADNAN NAPA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT SIX.
RT TEN SIXTY THREE YEAR OLD BUT
- HI HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME WE
GET AREA. HI MY NAME IS TO LET
THE SANCHEZ I AM A RESIDENT OF
MONTEREY COUNTY I'M ALSO A
REGISTERED NURSE AND MOTHER OF
TWO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. TEN TWENTY
THREE YOUR ALL THINGS SHE SAID
HELLO MY NAME LIAM CALLING FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND THAT
WILL BE IMPOSED SB EIGHT SIX SIX
THANK YOU. SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO. YES MY NAME IS RACHEL CORRIE
AND IT'S ACTUALLY EASIER TO AND
I DON'T OPPOSE I DON'T. ANY ALL
RIGHT THANK. NEXT THANK. FOR
THIRTY SIX. HELLO YEAH WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY SHOW OF THE
TEACHER AND PARENTS THREE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AT EIGHT EIGHT
SIX SIX THANK YOU. WHAT GOOD
NIGHT YEAR OPEN. MY NAME IS JACK
CODE I AM THE BECAUSE OF THE TRI
VALLEY REPUBLICANS AND THAT WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE EIGHT
SEVENTY SIX WIENER THE NOT ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. ONE ZERO ZERO
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS A MEMBER OF THE I AM A
PARENTS REPRESENTING MOUNTAIN
HOUSE PARENTS FOR CHOICE AND SAN
JOAQUIN I STRONGLY OPPOSE AT
EIGHT EIGHT THANK YOU BOTH
WIENER ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. NEXT NEXT IS Y. QUE
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. OUR MEN IN
AMERICA I AM A PARENT AND A
PARENT OF A DISABLED CHILD A MAN
WITH THE SACRAMENTO CITY AND
THEN ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT NINE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
EIGHT SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
LINE EIGHT FIFTY FIVE EUROPE AT. EIGHT FIFTY FIVE. EIGHT FIVE
WE HEAR YOU. SO WE'LL TRY LOW A
NINETEEN NINE NINETEEN PLEASE
AHEAD. BY NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ALL RIGHT WE'LL TRY NINE
NINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETY TWENTY FOUR. EUROPEN
NINE TWENTY FOUR. STE. IRATE
LINE CAN NINETY FOUR TO NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. JUST
PORSCHE FOXX WALKED INTO WITH
CAL HIGH OPPOSE IT EIGHT SIXTY
SIX IT WON'T WORK THANK YOU WILL
STOP AT. LIKE NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GOING. STE FOLLOW. ME YES
WE CAN- HI MY NAME IS TERRA FROM
RANCHO CORDOVA AND PART OF THE
PEOPLE'S MOVEMENT AND THE PEOPLE%
CONWAY AND I OPPOSE S. B. EIGHT
SIX SIX. THANK YOU. YEAH WE'LL
GO TO LINE UP A LEVEL FIVE YOU
ARE OPEN. BUT A. FIVE ELEVEN OH
FIVE ONE MORE SHOT. IRATE ELEVEN
OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. STE
HELLO MY NAME IS JENNIFER I AM A
RESIDENT OF STANISLAUS COUNTY
AND I OPPOSE SB EIGHT SIX X.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
LINE- ELEVEN TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
ELEVEN TEN. THAT'S THE BLAIR
CALLING FOR SUNNY CAL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AND JUST A
REMINDER YOU ALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIX POLICE. TEN FIFTY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. THANK FOUR GO
AHEAD WE HEAR YOU. HELLO WE GET
AREA. TO HELP IT DID FIFTY FOUR.
I WILL TRY TO GET NINETY SIX
BRED TEN NINETY SIX. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN. HI MY NAME IS
THE KNOCKED OVER AT THE MALL
FROM DANIELLE'S. CO FOUNDER OF
POWER TO THE PARENTS CAN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHT SIX SIX IT
WILL NOT WORK YOUR EMAIL. ELEVEN
A THREE YEAR OLD. STE STE.
ELEVEN THREE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TESTIFY. ONE MORE SHOT ELEVEN OH
THREE. ELEVEN OR THREE ELEVEN
THAT YOU. WELL YOU HAVE A NINETY
THREE OTHER YEAH GO AHEAD WE CAN
HEAR HOW. I'M WRITING AMY I'M IN
. CALIFORNIA RESIDENT ARE HELP
PROVIDER I STRONGLY S. H. WILL
NOT WORK THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
. SHE AND WE'RE IN GO TO LINE
ONE. ELEVEN FOURTEEN MISTER
CHAIR ELEVENTH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SANTA MONICA BARBARO CANNOT BOTH
RUN FRIDAY WORKING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NECK PLEASE HOLD FOR
THE LEVEL ELEVEN TWENTY YOU ARE
OLD. FRIENDLY WITH BURLY
CRABTREE AND I'M MY OWN AND THE
NORK FREEDOM ALLIANCE IN CLASS
COUNTY WE OPPOSE SB EIGHT THICK
PARTY THAT THANK YOU. ELEVEN
TWENTY THREE YOU ARE. HI THIS IS
RYAN DUCKY REPRESENTING WEST ACT
AND I'M STRONG IN AND SUPPORT
ELEVEN. THIRTY EIGHT SB SIX SIX
THANK YOU RT YOU. ELEVEN THIRTY
TO PLEASE CALL AT. HI MY NAME'S
HALEY HOUSTON I'M IN THOUSAND
OAKS CALIFORNIA AND I WANT TO
STRONG AT THE EIGHT SIX SIX.
THANK YOU. ELEVEN THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME ARE
STRUCK HOPES AT THE END OF TWO
ON BEHALF OF GRANADA HILLS
CHARTER PARENTS UNITED STRONG
OPPOSITION TO S. B. EIGHT SIX
SIX BERMAN WIENER ARE ADHERING
PLEASE ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE YOUR OPEN. HI THERE
ARE AND FOR NOW TOWN AND I
OPPOSE SB EIGHT SIX SIX. THANK
YOU. ELEVEN THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHEN GAP REGARD I
CALIFORNIA SB EIGHT SIX THANK
YOU THANK YOU. STE ELEVEN FORTY
FOR YOUR OPEN. YEAH HI MY NAME
IS NICOLE YEAH I'M NOT A MOTHER
AND HILL MEMBER OF MOM
CELEBRITIES PLASTER COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. RT
THANK YOU. ELEVEN FORTY SIX YOU
ARE OPEN. SAID JACKIE CALLIOPE
FROM L. A. COUNTY I'M CALLING IN
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT SIX SIX
THANK YOU FOR THE- STE. SEVEN
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEVEN THIRTY TWO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TESTIFY. ONE MORE SHOT AT
SEVEN THIRTY TWO. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL TRY LINE. SEVEN SIXTY
SEVEN. WE HEAR YOU SEVEN SIXTY
SEVEN HE FIRED. SEVEN SIXTY
SEVEN. WHY NINE OH SEVEN PLEASE
GO SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN EUROPA
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL TRY NINE OH SEVEN
GOING AT NINE OH SEVEN. MARGARET
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA. NUMBER
DATA. HAS STRONGLY OPPOSES RULES
ALREADY. I HAVE ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIR.
THEY DO HAVE A COUPLE MORE
QUEUING UP. THE OPERATOR. BY
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHTY TWO EUROPA
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHT NINETY
NINE EIGHTY TWO SKEWS ME THAT
WAS MY FAULT NINE EIGHTY TWO IF
YOU ARE A- HEY CAN YOU HEAR ME.
WE CAN'T. HI MY NAME IS- AND THE
MOTHER IS STILL PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER FROM ONE. ANTI TRUMP
INFO EIGHT EXPECT OUR THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE A FIFTY FIVE YOU ARE ALL.
BUT IF I DON'T. SUCH AS- NEXT
PLEASE. THANKS. TO WHY. B.
ELEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHAT IT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TESTIFY YOU'RE ALL SET. IRATE
WILL- TRY LINE ALL RIGHT OF
MODERATE WE NOW REACH THE
SEVENTY FIVE MINUTE MARK- I'LL
ALLOW THREE MORE MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY SO GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
R. ONE SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN YEAR
OLD BUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TESTIFY. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
GO TO LINE ELEVEN FIFTY NINE
ELEVEN FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CAROLINE
MCGRATH THE MOTHER OF TWO AND
NAPA COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB EIGHT SIXTY. THANK
YOU. I SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO.
WELL THE PROPOSAL ALSO OUTLINED
SEVEN THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. STE STE. ZERO SEVEN THIRTY TWO
WE HEAR YOU. STE. SEVEN THIRTY
TWO. ALL RIGHT TRY A LINE- LEVIN
FIFTEEN BECAUSE A LOT OF THE-
HELLO MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
SONORA I'M WITH LAWCENTER
EDUCATORS AND PARENTS UNITED OF
LAUP DISTRICT AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
ELEVEN SIXTY YOU ARE OPEN.
NUMBER LAURA ROSENBERGER HAIDAR
RIGHT POSES. THANK YOU. THREE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. STE
STE WELL. EIGHT THREE TWENTY
SIX. YOU ARE OPEN. WHAT THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIX MY
NAME IS JOHN MARINO I'M FROM
REDONDO BEACH AND I'M CALLING TO
OPPOSE. EIGHT SIX SIX. THANK YOU
ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE SIXTY FOUR. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TESTIFY BUT- RATE WILL
TRY. THREE TWENTY SIX. THREE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EUROPEN WE HEAR YOU. RETORT
THIRDS. ALL RIGHT SIX SEVENTY
SIX GO AHEAD SIX SIX. HI MY NAME
IS NICOLE DEAN FROM INTEREST I'M
A MOTHER OF TWO TEENAGE BOYS AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. FIGHTER FIFTY PARKER
AVE. WHAT. FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. RESTORATION FIFTY TO TESTIFY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ELEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR OFFICE. ELEVEN SEP
EIGHT. A LITTLE HELLO GO AHEAD.
YES I AM OPPOSED TO THE BILL I
CONSIDERED A CRIME AGAINST OUR
ANYTHING LIKE CARP LET ANY
REPORTERS PLEASE GO AT. ELEVEN
ELEVEN EIGHTY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TESTIFY. WELL FOR MORE SHOT
ELEVEN EIGHTY. ELEVEN NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS LAKHAN VERMA AND I HIGH PAUL
BUT IT'S STILL THANK YOU ARE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MODERATOR SO
WE NO ILL GO WELL BEYOND THE
FIVE MINUTES ALLOTTED. BUT LET'S
NOW TURN TO- THOSE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT
SIX SIX. YES YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. EIGHT SIX SIX. THESE Q.
OF MODERATE OU QUEUE UP THOSE
WE'VE EXHAUSTED THE OPPOSITION
BUT WOMEN OUT OF EXHAUST THE
OPPOSITION BUT WE'VE EXHAUSTED
THE TIME. FOR THE OPPOSITION
TESTIFIED SO. OKAY- AS MR CARE
SAID PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO FOR SUPPORT ONLY ON S.
B. EIGHT SIX SIX PLEASE SUPPORT
ONLY. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
THREE TWENTY SIX YOU ARE ALL.
YEAH HI MY NAME IS LEON MORGAN
I'M THIRTEEN YEARS OLD AND I
WOULD PROTECT US ON BEHALF OF
MALDIVIAN CALIFORNIA ARE
COUNTING ON YOU TO PASSAGE EIGHT
SIX SIX THANK YOU. OR THREE
FIFTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT ON
. EUROPEN THREE FIFTY. FRESHII
THREE FIFTY WHICH I TO CAST.
RIGHT THIS IS. OKAY WE'RE GONNA
GO TO LINE. ONE EIGHTY. WHAT
EIGHTY GO AHEAD. WHY ONE EIGHTY
WE CAN HEAR YOU. ALL RIGHT FOR
FOUR PLEASE CONTACT. STE WE'RE
GONNA GET HELLO. OR YEAH. FOUR
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO WE GET AREA. HI GUYS MY
NAME IS ALEXEY LISTLESS MEDICAL
SCHOOL GRADUATE AND A
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY OWNER
AND OPERATOR NOW THERE ARE THOSE
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN TODAY FOR
MY SUPPORT FOR AS THE EIGHT SIX
SIX. THANK YOU. FOR SIXTY SIX
PLEASE CALL AT. THIS WHO. FOUR
SIXTY SIX WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TESTIFY. THE SAME TO. AREA OF
ALL RIGHT THIRTY SO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
BORDEN ARE AND MOTHER TO IN FACT
I STRONG SUPPORT SB EIGHT FIFTY
SIX YOU. THANK YOU. FIVE FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR OPEN. THE
CRYPTOCURRENCY CARE PROTECT THAT
RETURNING THE PRO BACKED
SECURITY IN WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
ITSELF THANK YOU. FIVE SIXTY
FOUR YOUR OLD BUT- HELLO MY NAME
IS ALEX I'M AND MEMBER OF CASH
THAT THANKS FOR AT THE- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I SIXTY FIVE YEAR
OLD. HI MY NAME IS AVAILABLE BY
I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES I'M
CALLING I'VE BEEN YOU KNOW
COMPROMISED FILED AN ANTI DOCTOR
AND I STRONG SUPPORT THE FILM
THANK YOU. BY SIXTY SEVEN OLD.
HI MY NAME IS BENEFITTED ALL
THEM SAN DIEGO AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT HE EXPECTS. OF THANK YOU
FIVE THANK YOU A BY THE THREE
PLEASE GO. HELLO NAME IS.
HARDER'S THE DOES NOT GOING ON.
THANK YOU EIGHT SIX SIX THREE
YEAR OPEN. HI MY NAME KEVIN RAN
ON A SINGLE FATHER FROM
CALIFORNIA THE NEW YORKER AND
I'M STRONG OF. THE TEXAS THANK
YOU. SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
AHEAD. SIX SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY. SIX
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIX
THIRTY THREE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL TRY ONE SEVEN NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT. SEVEN NINETY EIGHT
EUROPEN. FROM HERE ME YES WE CAN. CALIFORNIA ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA TAKING AWAY PARENTAL
CONSENT IN CHILD ABUSE THIRTY NO
WHAT FLORIDA'S NEXT PLEASE. THE
SONG OPPOSED NEXT PLEASE STOP
LOOKING BYE FELICIA THAT WILL
ALREADY GET UP FOR THIS WORLD IS
RIGHT NOW SIGNED. SEVENTY THAT
NINE. RIGHT SEVENTY TWO EURO
FIRST. AIRING YES WE CAN'T.
RIGHT- YOUR BODY IS THAT THE
FONG- OFFICES THE FOURTEENTH
ZERO. EARLY NEXT. I NINETY FIVE
EURO. RIGHT. ACCORDING TO
MONTEREY COUNTY AND TRONG IMPOSE
A THREE PARTY NEXT NINE NINETY
NINETY GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
SOPHIA BURROWS I AM FROM EL
DORADO COUNTY AND I PROBABLY
SUPPORT BILL EIGHTY SIX. THANK
YOU. FORTY EIGHT THE CALL AT.
YES HELLO FEARON. YES I MEAN
THERE ARE THE BILL THANK YOU.
EARLY BY NINETY FIVE YOUR OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BONTA OPPOSED.
TEN EIGHTY YEAR OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YOU'RE ON. HELLO MY
NAME IS ARGHA ANSWER PANINIS I
LIVE IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I AM
A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD ROUTINES
REFLECTING THAT I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB SIX SIX. K. NEXT
EIGHTY NINE. YOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL YES YOUR HONOR. MY
NAME IS WILLIAM PRESS I LIVE IN
LONG BEACH AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. BY ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS RUNNING IN AND I DON'T AND
I'M FROM THE FRONT IS SOMETHING
AND I FAMILIES SB EIGHT SIX.
THANK YOU. ELEVEN FORTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YOU'RE ON
- YES YOU'RE ON THE YES WE CAN
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU- YOU CAN
WELL YES THAT. THIS IS DONNA
FROM SOUTHERN CAL. AND IN G.
NAME PLEASE STOP THIS TOMORROW
THANK YOU KNOW WHAT THE NEXT
PLEASE THANKS PLEASE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD NINE TWENTY. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS THE REAL IN
ORDER SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I'M
A MOTHER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL OKAY. WITHOUT TAKING
SUPPORT FOR S. B. EIGHT SIX SIX
NEXT CALLER IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU OUTLINED SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR OPEN. SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEARCH IN
SUPPORT- WILL MOVE ON TO NINE
SEVENTY SEVEN YEAR OLD THAT.
THANK SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH WELL WE GET YOU. OF
THIS OF THE ALREADY THANK WORD
TAKE RIGHT NOW TAKING. OTHER
COLORS IN SUPPORT. ELEVEN
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ELEVEN
FIFTEEN PROJECTED TO FIND
SUPPORT TO SB. EIGHT SIXTY SIX.
WIENER WE UP ALL RIGHT NEXT
COLOR NEXT CALLER. FOR THE- NEXT
CALLER LET ME SEVENTY EIGHT ZERO
UP. I HAVE A QUALIFIED LEVEL
SEVENTY EIGHT YEAR ALTHOUGH JACK
SUPPLY. YES WELL I HAVE CURRENT
NEXT PLEASE SUPPORT EACH OTHER
THESE AHEAD SIR SIXTY SEVEN IF
YOU ARE. SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
REJECT TESTIFY. WE WILL TRY LINE
NINE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE CAN HEAR YOU. STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHAMBER KNOWN TO YOU SUPPORT AT
. HI THERE MY NAME INSTEAD OF
YOUR CUTTING SHOW FOR I'M A
STUDENT FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND IN THE MEDIA
COMPROMISED VIGIL I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AT EIGHT SIX SIX THANK
YOU. TEN THIRTY EIGHT YOU ARE
OPEN. HELLO I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU WE'RE NOW TAKING
SUPPORT NINE NINE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR OPEN NINE SEVENTY SEVEN. GO
AHEAD. WHAT BY AT THE SENATE
BILL BUFFALO. THIRTY NEXT ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
HAVE BEEN INJURED MEMBERS JUST
SOME RANDOM CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
STEEL THANK YOU. ELEVEN NINETY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY I'M
CALLING FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
DEMONIC THAT ALREADY THANK YOU
WERE IN SUPPORT. NINE SEVENTY
SEVEN YEAR OLD THING. THE WE
AREA. CONFIDENCE FROM UP THANK
YOU FOR TAKING FARLOW ONE. IF
YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PROBABLE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M
CALLING FROM SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER FOR PREP WORK FOR THAN TO
PREDATORS YOU DON'T HIDE YOUR
PERFECT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BLIND TWELVE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ADMINISTRATIVE
OFFICE I'M FROM PALESTINIAN
HAMAS ANGELES COUNTY AND I'M AND
YOU KNOW COMPROMISED I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB EIGHT SIX ALL RIGHT
MODERATE WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS-
WE'RE GONNA TAKE TWO MORE
COLORS- THOSE WHO ARE ON THE
PHONE LINES IN OPPOSITIN WE'VE-
TAKEN OVER EIGHTY MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION SO- WILL
TAKE TWO MORE COLORS AND THEN I
APOLOGIZE THOSE ARE WAITING IN
SUPPORT BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND SHUT THAT DOWN ALL
RIGHT. TWO MORE COLORS. OKAY
MISTER CHAIR- WE'RE GOING TO
SHOW LINE TWELVE TWELVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THEY WENT OUT OF Q.
LET'S GO TO LINE- TWELVE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. BONTA
MONTEREY COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE
S. C. H. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO THE
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU TWELVE
TWENTY FOUR EUROPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS KIMBERLY WILL I'M A PART
OF THE LABOR JOHN UP WHICH THE
USER EDUCATION ACT ORGANIZATION
WHICH REPRESENTS OVER FOUR
THOUSAND STUDENTS ACROSSTHE
STATE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU TO ALL RIGHTY.
THANK YOU WITH AND APOLOGIZE TO
THOSE WHO ARE WAITING- WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT SIX
SIX- UNFORTUNATELY- BECAUSE OF
OUR TECHNOLOGY WE'RE HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME- THE-
DISTINGUISHING THOSE OPPOSED TO
THOSE IN SUPPORT WE'RE RELYING
ON THOSE WHO- WERE OPPOSED TO.
BASICALLY AFTER THEY'VE USED
THEIR EIGHTY MINUTES TO
RELINQUISH THEIR- PHONE LINE FOR
THOSE IN SUPPORT THAT'S NOT BEEN
DONE SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY AGAIN HAVE TO CUT
OFF THOSE IN SUPPORT. SO LET ME
BRING IT BACK HERE TO THE
COMMITTEE- QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SENATE YOUR
QUESTIONS WHAT KELSEY SEMI CAL
SKI THEN CENTERED. SENATE WINNER
WE HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION
ABOUT THE BRAIN DEVELOPMENT- YOU
KNOW THE DIFFERENT STAGES OF- OF
YOUTH IN ON PAGE NINE OF OUR
STAFF REPORT THEY TALK ABOUT. I
AM. EDUCATE EPIC ABOUT MINORS
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENTS
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES ARE
EVEN SOME CONDITIONS OF ANXIETY
AND THE STAFF REPORT SUGGESTS
THAT THERE MAY BE A NEED FOR
GUARD RAILS TO BE ADDED CAN YOU
ADDRESS THAT- SURE OF ANYTHING
OR JUST REFER I DO IT FOR
SOMEONE THE CHAIR- FROM THE
BOTTOM MY HEART FOR PRESIDING
OVER A CHALLENGER HEARING I ALSO
JUST WANT EXPRESSED SERVE. OF
THE BILL WHO WERE TRYING TO CALL
AND I AND I TOTALLY AGREE WITH
THE TEARS APPROACH TO THE
SUBJECT HAD NO OTHER CHOICE
BECAUSE OF THE EXTREMELY ABUSIVE
FOR PEOPLE KNOWING THAT THERE
WAS AN HOUR AND FIFTEEN MINUTES
FROM POSITION CALLING HOUR AND
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR SUPPORT
CALLING AND WANT TO GIVE
EVERYONE EQUAL TIME AND THE
OPPONENTS CLEARLY RANGING
ABUSIVE BEHAVIOR BY TRYING TO
DROWN OUT THE SUPPORTERS AND BY
CALLING AND A SUPPORTERS AND I
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS TO THE
SUPPORTERS THAT WE HEAR YOU- AND
WE APPRECIATE- EVERYONE SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION- AND IT'S JUST%
UNFORTUNATE THAT SOME PEOPLE TRY
TO DROWN OUT OTHER PEOPLE- BUT
SEVERAL ACCOUNTS YOU TO ANSWER
YOUR- QUESTION- JUST TO BE
CLEAR. THAT THE IDEA OF INFORMED
CONSENT FOR MEDICAL TREATMENT
FOR ANYONE WHETHER YOU ARE A
TEENAGER OR WHETHER YOU'RE
SEVENTY FIVE YEARS OLD IS NOT A
NEW ONE UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW OR
UNDER- FIVE AT THE GOAL
GUIDELINES FOR TREATMENT
INFORMED CONSENT- IS SOMETHING
THAT EXISTS AND IT TO SOMEONE
WHO WILL SAY WHETHER BECAUSE OF
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES OR OR
OTHER OR OR SOME SORT OF
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT WHETHER
THEY'RE FOURTEEN YEARS OLD OR
WHETHER THEY'RE FIFTY YEARS OLD
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IN TERMS
OF ETHICAL GUIDELINES FOR A
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER THEY HAVE
TO TAKE. INTO ACCOUNT THAT IS
NOT THAT IS NOTHING NEW- AGAIN
FOR OTHER TEENAGER WHETHER
YOU'RE OVER EIGHTEEN IN
ADDITION- WE CALIFORNIA AND CAL
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW FOR MANY
MANY YEARS WE HAVE- ASPELL IT IS
A CONCERN THAT IS LESS THAT IS
LOWER THAN EIGHTEEN- AS I STATED
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE STATE
AND A VERY THOROUGH. ANALYSIS
FOR THE FIRST TIME OF ACTION.
FOR MONTHS HEALTH TREATMENT
OTHER VARIOUS KIND OF. TREAT
AGENT. IS AND THE FOR SOMEONE
WHO IS A FOR. IN TO. THERE
LIVING ON THEIR OWN FINANCIALLY
SUPPORTING THEMSELVES. IT'S
FIFTEEN MINUTES BUT NOT FOR A
LONG A LONG TIME SO. THAT IS
ALWAYS SOMETHING PROVIDER HAS TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE MATTER WHO
THEY'RE TREATING IN WHAT
CONTEXT. IS THIS PERSON CAPABLE
OF. CONSENTING AND SO WITH THIS
LAW DOES NOT. DEVIATE FROM THAT
OR OR OR CHANGE THAT OR CHANGE
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA HAS LONG
ALLOWED TEENAGERS. TO OBTAIN
CERTAIN KINDS OF TREATMENT
INCLUDING CERTAIN KINDS OF
VACCINES- WITHOUT SAID WE DID
SEE THAT STATEMENT IN THE
ANALYSIS AND WE ARE OF COURSE-
ALWAYS OPEN THE GOING BACK AND
LOOKING MAKING SURE. THAT
EVERYTHING IS SOLID- BUT THAT'S. THAT'S MY RESPONSE. YES MISTER
THROWING- SEVEN OPPOSITION SAYS
THIS- THESE- NOTICES THAT CAME
OUT TO AGO THIS. ON ITS- TO MAKE
THIS. S. B. THE SIX SIX ACOSTA.
STAFF ANALYSIS. INDICATED IT'S
NOT SUCH A CLEAR CUT- DECISIONS
FOR YOU. GAVE ME ABSOLUTELY AND-
SO THAT RULING WAS ONE. LOWER
COURT RULING BY ONE JUDGE. IN
THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA- THAT
IS- THAT PERSONAL IT DOESN'T
APPLY TO CALIFORNIA NOT SOME
SORT OF IT WAS ABOUT THAT
SPECIFIC DC LAW BY ONE JUDGE IN
THAT CAN BE APPEALED BUT I'M
ASSUMING IT'S BEEN APPEALED- IN
ADDITION IF YOU LOOK AT THE
LOGIC OF THAT DECISION I AND I
AGREE THAT WITH THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. IT IS WRONG
BUT JUDGE WAS JUST WRONG- AND
THE RULING WAS SAT AND FEDERAL
LAW NATIONAL NATIONAL CHILDHOOD
VACCINE INJURY ACT PREEMPTS
LOCAL OR A STATEMENT OF FACT AT
LEAST A LITTLE LAW THAT- LOWER
THE AGE OF CONSENT. TO LOW
EIGHTEEN- AND THAT THAT'S ON
PRESS. STATES HAVE LAW. HAD THE
A STAR FOREVER TO DETERMINE AGE
OF CONSENT FOR ANY GIVEN TYPE OF
HEALTH CARE AND STATES HAVE DONE
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE IT. OTHER
STATES HAVE DONE A LONG BEFORE
THAT ACT WAS ENACTED SINCE THAT
ACT WAS ENACTED AND THERE'S NO
EXPRESS PREEMPTION IN THE
FEDERAL LAW AND THERE'S NO
CONFLICT AND SO- I RESPECT
RESPECT TO THAT ONE LOWER COURT
JUDGES IN DC- I DISAGREE- AND
AGREE WITH THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND- OF AND IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT BINDING. ON US
SOMEONE TO FILE A LAWSUIT IF
THIS IS PASSING THE LAW EVERY
RIGHT TO DO THAT JUST LIKE TO DO
WITH ANY LAW. AND ORDER AND JUST
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM CLARIFY ARE WE
REPLACING THE PARENTS RIGHT TO
MAKE DECISIONS WITH THEIR FOR
THEIR CHILDREN'S HEALTH WITH THE
STATE'S RIGHT TO. MAKE THESE
DECISIONS NO THIS IS NOT A
SITUATION WHERE THE STATE WILL
MAKE THE DECISION THIS IS
EMPOWERING THE TEENAGER TO MAKE
THAT DECISION JUST LIKE WE-
EMPOWER TEAMS TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS AND OTHER HEALTH CARE
CONTACTS. THE WHAT KELSEY SIR.
THANK MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M A CO
FOR THE IN THEN I ALSO THAT WE
LIKE A- IF I COULD- MR MCGREGOR
. OF FOLLOW WITH HIM- ON THAT DC
QUESTION IF THAT WOULD BE OKAY
SURE MISSING MAKING REYNOLDS I
KNOW HE'S ROACH THE MICROPHONE
THANK YOU THANK- THE SENATE
LEADER ON I'VE- THE CMA HAD
SOME. VERY COMPELLING-
STATEMENTS THAT I AGREE WITH.
BUT THERE'S NOTHING IN THE BILL
THAT WOULD REQUIRE A PHYSICIAN'S
. CONSOLE ON THIS AS THE T. IF
THE TEENAGERS GOING TO SCHOOL
AND CONSENTING TO THESE VACCINES
. THE THERE THERE'S NOTHING THAT
COMPELS THE SCHOOL OR THE TEAM
OR ANY ANY OTHER HEALTH CARE
WORKER TO CONSOLE WITH THAT. IN
NATURE'S PEDIATRICIANS AT
CORRECT. THIS LAW DOES NOT
AFFECT WHAT HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS ARE AUTHORIZED TO
VACCINATE SOMEONE EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LAW. AUTHORIZES WHO
COUNTING CANNOT ADMINISTER- THE
PEOPLE AUTHORIZED TO ADMINISTER
VACCINES. OR TRAINS THEY HAVE
ETHICAL REQUIREMENTS THEY'RE
BOUND BY CALIFORNIA LAW AND BY
THEIR OWN PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS. AND THIS WILL BE NO
DIFFERENT THAN ANY OTHER
SITUATION WHERE A TEENAGER UNDER
CAL LAW AS LONG BEEN ABLE TO SEE
. HEALTH CARE WHETHER IT'S FROM
POSITION OR WHATEVER.
PROFESSIONALS AUTHOR TO PROVIDE
HEALTHCARE AND JUST AS CHANGE
RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU IN THE
REASON I BRING IT UP IS YOU KNOW
MY FAMILY WE'VE WE'VE HAD A
GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
PEDIATRICIAN AND YOU KNOW THAT'S
RIGHT. CME'S ARE FROM POINT SOME
DEGREE BUT I DO I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT THE WITNESSES THAT- AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE LEADING
WITNESSES THE SHARED. YOU KNOW
THAT THEIR CHILD HAD- HEALTH
CONDITION WHEN THEY WERE AN
INFANT THAT THE SCHOOL OR YOUR A
CURRENT HEALTHCARE PROVIDER
WOULD NOT HAVE ANY OF THAT
HISTORY. WITHOUT CONSTANT
WITHOUT CONSOLING WITH THE
CHILD'S PITTED SO IF THAT WAS
THE ONE YOU KNOW ON THE
GUARDRAILS IT WAS IN THE BILL- I
THINK IT WOULD MOVE ME CLOSER-
TO BEING LESS- ADVERSE TO THE-
AND SO SWITCHING. I DIDN'T WANT
TO ASSISTANCE MISTER MCREYNOLDS
BROUGHT IT UP THE DC CASE. IF
YOU COULD JUST TAKE IS SOME
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT THE AUTHOR
TOOK TO DESCRIBE. THEIR SIDE OF
MR MCCONNELL'S COULD KINDA
EXPAND A LITTLE BIT ON THAT DC
CASE PLEASE SIR- SIR JOHN
SPECIFIC ROUTES OF YOU DIRECT
YOUR COMMENTS TO THE CHAIR. IT
CERTAINLY IS THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR YOUR INSIGHT IN YOUR
ATTENTION THAT PARTICULAR CASE.
I THINK THE SENATOR WIENER'S
COMMENTS ARE ILLUMINATING THAT
ESSENTIALLY. SB EIGHT SIXTY SIX
JUST TAKES A DIFFERENT VIEW AND
TAKES THE VIEW THAT THE-
DECISION OUT OF THE DC COURT-
WAS SIMPLY WRONG. EIGHT HE'S
CORRECT IN THAT A DECISION FROM
A LOWER FEDERAL COURT IN DC- IS
NOT BINDING OR CONTROLLING ON
THIS BODY. BUT IT CERTAINLY
PRESENTS SOME LOW HANGING FRUIT
TO THOSE OF US WHO ARE READY-
PERCEIVE A LOT OF AND ILLEGALITY
WITHIN A S. S. B. EIGHT SIXTY
SIX- IT LAYS OUT A- PRETTY
EXTENSIVE. FRAMEWORK FOR HOW TO
ATTACK THIS BILL. AND GET TO
SOME OF THAT GENERAL INTEREST
POINTS EIGHT IN. OF COURSE THERE
ARE DISTINCTIONS BETWEEN THE LAW
THAT WAS PASSED IN DC COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS PICKED UP ON THIS AS
WELL. I OF COURSE THERE ARE
DISTINCTIONS BETWEEN S. B. EIGHT
SIXTY SIX IN ALL OF THE OTHER
STATE LAWS AND RECITED. IN
SUPPORT OF IT IS- AUTHORIZING
VARIOUS TYPES OF- HEALTH
EMANCIPATION IF YOU WILL FOR
MINORS AND OTHER STATES THERE
ARE ALWAYS SOME DISTINCTIONS.
BUT WHAT YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT AND
YOU KNOW WE KNOW AS LAWYERS WE
ASK OURSELVES. ARE THESE
DISTINCTIONS WITHOUT A
DIFFERENCE. AND I WOULD SUBMIT
THAT THE ARE PARTICULARLY
BECAUSE OF THE INSIDES OF THE
FEDERAL JUDGE IN DC AND ECHOING
THAT IS A LEADER TO EARLIER. OF
SOME OF THE SAME KINDS OF
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED. IN THE OPPOSITION
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
THE FOR INSTANCE WHAT YOU HEARD
FROM PARENTS AS WELL AS FROM
OTHERS. ABOUT THE BACKGROUND OF
KIDS WHO DON'T KNOW THEIR OWN.
MEDICAL HISTORY ESPECIALLY FROM
A YOUNG AGE THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT THE COURT IN. DC PICKED UP
ON. IT SO THE THING THAT I THE
KEY THE COURTS HERE WOULD BE
VERY. ATTUNED AND SO- I THINK
THAT'S WHY THE DECISION FROM THE
DC COURT WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE-
ALL OF YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT YOU KNOW DECIDE FOR
YOURSELVES WITH THE DISTINCTIONS
ARE- AND WHAT THE SIMILARITIES
ARE IN. I BELIEVE YOU'LL FIND
MORE SIMILARITIES THAN
DIFFERENCES. PARTY THANK YOU
MISS MAKE ROUNDS. SENATE JONES
AS THANK YOU RICHARD YEAH THAT'S
ALL I HAD- I'M I'M HAVING A HARD
TIME- SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY-
I'LL BE VOTING NO AND I'LL JUST
CLOSE WITH KIND OF AN ANECDOTAL.
ANYHOW COMMENT WHEN I REMEMBER I
WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY WE HAD A
BILL AND- THAT WAS PROHIBITING.
TEENS FROM GOING TO US SPRAY TAN
SON BOOTH- WITHOUT PARENT TOOK
CONSENT AND- I JUST THINK SOME
OF THE ARGUMENTS ON THIS PARABLE
CONSENT. BREAKS DOWN WHEN YOU
LOOK AT. A SOME MEMBERS ON THIS
COMMITTEE THAT VOTED FOR THAT
BILL TO BAN. TEEN GIRLS FROM
GOING TO GET A SUNTAN- BECAUSE
HE CAN'T MAKE THAT DECISION BUT
WE'RE ALLOWING TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN YEAR OLDS. TO MAKE THE
DECISION TO GET A VACCINE AND
MEDICAL TREATMENT SELF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SIR JONES
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS I
DON'T- YES EARLIER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THIS IS THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE SO THE DEBATE ON THE
DC CASE HAS BEEN. ON THE WALL
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO ASK A LITTLE
ABOUT THE ACTUAL. PROGRAM IS
THERE EVIDENCE. THAT SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE EXPRESSED
HERE. ARE CAME INTO PLAY IN DC
WHEN THE AGE OF CONSENT WAS
ELEVEN WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED
WAS IT CONSIDERED A SUCCESS WHAT
WERE THE ISSUES. BUT I MEAN I.
THE THAT WOULD BE A QUESTION FOR
THE WASHINGTON DC OF A FALSE OR
THAT'S WHAT I WAS SUGGESTING TO
YOUR WAS GONNA YES WE- I'VE NOT
HEARD OF ANY PROBLEMS- THERE-
AND- WE CERTAINLY CAN ACQUIRE-
WITH WATCHINGWHAT DC OFFICIALS
BUT WE'VE NOT HEARD OF ANY FIVE
ARE ARE OBVIOUSLY SUGGEST IF
THERE'D BEEN PROBLEMS WE WOULD
HAVE HEARD ABOUT IT IN THE LIKE
THE TESTIMONY BUT IT STILL WAS
A- MATTER. DURING THE OPINIONS
OF PROBLEMS HERE TWENTY OPINIONS
THEN THEN A SIMILAR QUESTION
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE EARLIER AGE
OF CONSENT IN CALIFORNIA FOR
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT WITH THE
EARLIER AGE OF CONSENT IN
CALIFORNIA FOR SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASES HAVE WE
HEARD. OF THAT THEIR ROLE.
ISSUES THAT WOULD TURN ON THIS
THAT HAVE COME OUT OF BOTH OF
THOSE NO WE WOULD NOT AND WHAT I
WILL SAY IS IN THIS WHOLE NOTION
THAT KIDS DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THEIR HEALTH HISTORY- YOU
COULD SAY THAT WELL THEY
SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO GO AND
PICK. YOU KNOW OUR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HEALTH CARE PHYSICAL
TREATMENT WOULD THANK YOU FOR
SERIOUS INJURY BECAUSE THEY
DON'T THEY CAN'T RECITE THEIR
OWN- HISTORY AND I'M SURE THEIR
KIDS BACK OR GREATER RECITING
THEIR OWN HEALTH CARE HISTORY
ABOUT YOUR EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD I
BET YOU THERE ARE SEVEN YEAR
OLDS WHO CAN'T RECITE OR CAN'T
REMEMBER THEIR ENTIRE HEALTHCARE
HISTORY I CAN SAY WITH
CONFIDENCE A FIFTY ONE. BUT I
CAN REMEMBER EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENED TO ME THE ENTIRE FIFTY
ONE YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN ALIVE
AND SO I YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
PEOPLE PERFECT HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS. ARE TRAINED. TO
ASK. AND TO AND TO HELP DEAL AND
PEOPLE WHO MAY NOT RE EVERYTHING
THAT'S A VERY VERY COMMON.
SITUATION FOR IT I THINK FOR ANY
KIND OF HEALTH CARE PROVIDED
THAT THERE ARE TIMES THAT YOU
HAVE A PTIENT. THAT FOR
WHATEVER REASON DOESN'T KNOW
EVERYTHING ABOUT THEIR OWN
HEALTH CARE HISTORY OR CAN'T
REMEMBER EVERYTHING OR MIGHT
MISS REMEMBER. AND SAY ONE THING
BUT REALLY SOMETHING ELSE
HAPPENED. AND HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS ARE TRAINED HOW TO
NAVIGATE THAT AND SO THE BILL
AND HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
HAVE BEEN NAVIGATING THE AS YOU
KNOW SENATOR- AROUND MENTAL
HEALTH AND OTHER AREAS OF HEALTH
CARE. FOR A LONG TIME AND SO
THEY KNOW HOW TO DO IT. I DON'T
KNOW HOW TO DO IT HERE. WELL
THERE WAS A- YOU KNOW THE VOTERS
HAVE VOTED ON. A NUMBER OF TIMES
THE PARENTAL RIGHTS WITH REGARD
TO- GETTING REPRODUCTIVE
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE THAT WERE
YOUNGER AND ONE OF THE
INTERESTING POLLING OUT COM
CIVIL WAR IS THAT IN GENERAL IF
. PEOPLE FELT BY PARENTS FELT
LIKE THEY SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT
FOR THEIR OWN KIDS BUT THEY FELT
THAT THERE WERE OTHER FAMILY
STEP. THAT MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN
AS RESPONSIBLE AND I THOUGHT IT
WAS IMPORTANT TO GRANT THAT IN
THE BALLOT BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY
THOUGHT MIGHT BE EXISTED IN
OTHER PLACES A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT CAME UP- THERE WAS AN ISSUE
ABOUT LIABILITY- COULD YOU
RESPOND TO THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE EXPRESSED ABOUT. SURE WE
HAVE- THERE'S A FEDERAL LAW THAT
COMPLETELY OCCUPIES FIELD AND
GOVERNS- LIABILITY OR
COMPENSATION FOR VACCINE INJURY
OCCURS ARE EXTREMELY RARE AND
WHEN THEY DO OCCUR THERE IS A
FEDERAL PROCESS FOR SEEKING
COMPENSATION AND NOT APPLY HERE.
BECAUSE NUMBER KIDS HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED FOR A LONG TIME- AND
SOMETIMES ON THEIR OWN EACH
PEOPLE YOU'RE HAPPY- OTHERWISE A
PARENT OR GUARDIAN AND OF A
VACCINE INJURY OCCURS THERE IS A
PROCESS TO GO THROUGH- TO GET
COMPENSATION AND THIS DOESN'T IN
ANY WAY CHANGE I. AND SO THAT
THAT LIABILITY SYSTEM IS WHAT IT
IS A REMAIN THAT WAY THE BILL
DOESN'T CHANGE NOR COULD REACH
BUT THERE WAS AN IMPLICATION IN
THE TESTIMONY THAT SOME HOW
DOCTORS ARE FAMILIES WOULDN'T
KNOW WHAT THIS BILL PASSED WELL
AND SO. DOES THAT. PREJUDICE
THAT YOUR STATE YEAH AND IT THIS
BILL. DOESN'T CHANGE FOR PERRIN
TO ALLOW. TO NOTE THERE ARE.
THOSE EXISTING LAWS WANT ONE A
CHILD TO. THERE'S EXIST MEDICAL
CONFIDENTIALITY LAW- LIMITING
WHAT A PARENT IS ALLOWED TO KNOW
ABOUT THE KIDS. AND MET HEALTH
CARE TREATMENT WITHOUT THE
CONSENT. OF THE CHILD NOT
EXISTING LAW ONE SECURE TERMS
TWELVE YOU DO NOT HAVE COMPLETE
BROAD ACCESS AS A PARENT TO
EVERY ASPECT OF YOUR KIDS
HEALTHCARE. AND SO WHATEVER
CONCERNS PEOPLE HAVE ABOUT THAT
THAT EXISTS. TODAY IF A KID HAS
AN ADVERSE REACTION. THAT'S NOT
GOING BE. A SECRET IN TERMS OF
COMPENSATION POTENTIALLY AND
THEIR PARENTS WHAT EVERY ABILITY
TO FILE FOR COMPENSATION FOR
THAT CHILD. AND YOU YOU
INDICATED THAT THAT YOU BELIEVE
THAT THAT IS RARE. THE DEAD THE
FACT THAT THIRD ENTRIES A RARE
AND YET THERE WAS- TESTIMONY
BELIEVED THAT IT HAPPENED TO
THEIR KIDS HOW DO YOU PROPOSE TO
GO. NO ONE ARGUES THAT VACCINE
INJURIES NEVER HAPPENED WITH THE
DATE THAT THAT NO ONE IS SAYING
THAT AND THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TESTIFIED ABOUT THEIR KIDS. BUT
THAT'S BETTER EXPERIENCE AND I'M
NOT IN ANY WAY DISPUTING WHAT
THEY SAID ABOUT THEIR CHILD- BUT
- THERE'S ALSO THE TENS OF
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS. OF
CHILDREN WHO WERE VACCINATED.
WE'RE NOT BOXING INJURED. AND
WHO WERE ABLE TO AVOID.
ATTENTIONAL GETTING VERY SICK OR
DYING FROM MEASLES- HI I IMAGINE
THAT THERE ARE RARE INSTANCES IN
WHICH THE POLIO VACCINE HARM
SOMEONE BUT BUT THAT AGAINST ALL
THE CHILDREN THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN DEBILITATED PARALYZED OR
DEAD. HAD WE NOT HAD A MASS
VACCINATION CAMPAIGN FOR POLIO.
AND SOYOU YOU LOOK AT THOSE
INJURIES. I'M EMPLOYEE WAS A
GREAT EXAMPLE I WASN'T I WASN'T
ALIVE DURING THE HORRIBLE YOU
MIGHT PARENTS OR- GRANDPARENTS
OF TALK TO ME ABOUT IT. THE
ABSOLUTE NIGHTMARE AND FEAR THAT
SOCIETY LIVE FOR KNOWING EVERY
YEAR. THAT SOME NUMBER OF KIDS
WE'RE GONNA GET POLIO AND THEY
MIGHT NO LONGER BE ABLE TO USE
THEIR ARMS THEY MIGHT NOT BE
ABLE TO WALK ANYMORE OR THEY
MIGHT DIE MIT POWER ALLIES. I
THANK GOD WE GOT THE POLIO
VACCINE ACTUALLY DID A MASS
VACCINATION CAMPAIGN. AND WE
DIDN'T HAVE SOCIAL MEDIA TO
SPREAD MASS MISINFORMATION ABOUT
THE POLIO VACCINE. AND CONGRESS
SET UP A COMPENSATION STRUCTURE
FOR THE VERY RARE INSTANCE IN
WHICH SOMEONE IS INJURED. BUT
HOW MANY MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS AND TENS OF
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ARE EITHER
ALIVE OR NOT PARALYZED TODAY.
BECAUSE WE HAD A MASS POLIO
VACCINATION CAMPAIGN. AND
BECAUSE WE LET PEOPLE GET
VACCINATED SO I AM NOT ANYWAY
SAYING THAT. THE PEOPLE'S
EXPERIENCE AND THEIR LIFE
EXPERIENCE AND WHAT AND AS A KID
WAS INJURED. THAT BAD THAT'S A
TERRIBLE THING AND THAT IS WHAT
THEY HAVE ARE LIVING WITH AND I
AND I HONOR THAT AND I'M NOT
THIS. THAT IN ANY WAY. BUT THEN
WE HAVE TO AT THE BIG PICTURE OF
THE MANY NNE OF. WHO HAVE
HEALTHIER LIVES NOW BECAUSE
EGGMAN OXIDATIVE. AND THEN
MISTER CHAIR BUT TO MAKE. I
THINK ONE OF THE MOST DIFFICULT
THINGS- ABOUT BEING IN THE
LEGISLATURE. IS THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN TIMES THAT ISSUES ARE
REPRESENTED TO BE BLACK AND
WHITE. BUT IT IS ACTUALLY THE
PRACTICAL CHOICE OF WHAT'S IN
FRONT OF US IT HAPPENED THIS
MORNING ON THE FLOOR- BECAUSE
THE MICRO ITEM THAT CAME IN
FRONT OF THIS IT WAS A CHOICE.
BETWEEN THIS BIG COMPROMISE AND
WHAT WOULD GO TO THE BALLOT IT
WASN'T A CHOICE. REALLY BETWEEN
THE CURRENT SITUATION. AND THAT
COMPROMISE AND IT ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORLD TICKETS IT
WHEN TREES DIE. OF THE BIOMASS
PROCESS IS NOT ENVIRONMENTALLY
SOUND BUT THOSE TREES HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE MILLION TREES ARE
GOING TO JURY FORCED TO CREATE
METHOD SO IT'S A CHOICE BETWEEN.
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT NOT BE
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND BIOMASS IT
AND THAT. IT AND. D. G. YOU JUST
READ TO YOUR PARENTS HI EITHER
EIGHT OR NINE. WHEN OURS IN LINE
AND A POLIO Q. A SUGAR WITH
POLICE. AND IT WAS- AND THERE
WAS A IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD THAT
GOT POLIO BEFORE WE DID THAT
NUMBER IN THAT CASE IT IS A MORE
MINOR THING BUT HE COULDN'T LIST
ARMS OR ABOVE A CERTAIN LEVEL.
AND IT WAS A VERY VERY REAL FEAR
. WE ALL FELT LIKE AS KIDS WE
WERE SUBJECT TO THAT. AND SO
THEN ONCE AGAIN IT BECOMES A
CHOICE IS IT IT IS A CHOICE
BETWEEN. THE POSSIBILITY OF
HAVING THAT SITUATION. FOR THE
MASS VACCINATION WITH WHICH IN
ESSENCE PREVENTED IT FOR MANY OF
US IN IN WHAT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED AND I THINK. THAT'S THE
DIFFICULTY ABOUT THIS AND IT
WASN'T. NECESSARILY REPRESENTED
IN SOME OF THE TESTIMONY BECAUSE
IT WAS REPRESENTED AS AN
ABSOLUTE. WHAT WHEN THERE'S A
GRADIENT OF CHOICE HERE. IT IS
AN WHAT IT IS AND THERE THERE IS
AN IT I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS IN
THERE AND WE HAD A SIMILAR
CONTENTIOUS HEARING. I HAD TO
SAY TO SOMEBODY THAT WAS
TESTIFYING THAT RUDENESS WAS
JUST NOT PERSUASIVE. AND IT'S
LIKE I WAS LISTENING CLOSELY TO
THE TESTIMONY AND IT'S THE
REASON WHY. I ASKED YOU ABOUT
SOME OF THE PRACTICAL FACTS THAT
WERE PRESENTED IN THE TESTIMONY.
THE WEATHER WAS THE LIABILITY.
FOR THE REALITIES OF THE DC
THING AGAINST THE LEGAL PART.
BECAUSE I THINK THOSE THAT IS
THE CHOICE IN FRONT OF US AND IT
IS WEIGHING. A CHOICE THAT IS
NOT AS CLEAR CUT BUT ONE THAT WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH SO. I KNOW IS
ESSENTIALLY THE STOP. ON A
LENGTHY DISCUSSION AND I THINK
SAID THAT THE ISSUES HAVE BEEN
LAID ON THE TABLE. IN A VERY
CLEAR WAY AND FOR ME NOW. GIVEN
THE CHOICE IT'S LIKE I WILL VOTE
TO MOVE ALONG AND I THINK SAID.
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT IN THE
HEATED DISCUSSION THAT EXISTS.
TO HONOR. ARE THE CONCERNS THAT
ARE RAISED AND MAKE SURE THEY
ARE ADDRESSED AND I THINK YOU
HAVE DONE A REASONABLE JOB. OF
ADDRESSING THE SPECIFIC THINGS
THAT WERE THAT WERE RAISED IN
THIS SO. I KNOW IT'S DIFFICULT
TO AND- BUT- I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THIS ENGINE
STORY THANK YOU SAID EARLIER
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS. THE
SENATOR ALSO THANK YOU- I KNOW
YOU MADE REFERENCE TO IT BUT IF
YOU COULD JUST- ZOOM IN ON. THE. NEED TO BE INFORMED. I THINK
BY EVERYBODY IN PARTICULAR
COURSE. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
YOUNGER- FOR OUR YOUNGER
DAUGHTERS AND SONS WHAT WOULD
YOU SAY TO THE ISSUE OF ARE THEY
PROPERLY INFORMED HOW WILL WE
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE INFORMED
THE WAY THAT THEY SHOULD BE
SURE- I JUST. OF COURSE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TEENAGERS ARE NOT
TALK ABOUT SEVEN YEAR OLDS- AND-
I I'M NOT A PHYSICIAN I'M NOT A
PHARMACIST I'M NOT A I'M NOT A
NURSE- BUT THOSE PROFESSIONALS
VEGAS EXTENSIVELY TRAINED- AND-
OUR THEIR JOB IS KNOWING HOW TO
TALK TO PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT
AGES- AND HOW TO ASK QUESTIONS
AND HOW TO FERRET OUT
INFORMATION- AND HOW TO MAKE
SURE THAT A PERSON. BUT DOES
HAVE THE ABILITY TO CONSENT TO
ANY KIND OF GIVEN- ANY DIFFERENT
FORM OF HEALTH CARE- THE FORMS
OF HEALTH CARE THAT TEENAGERS
CAN GET IN ON THAT ARE MUCH MORE
INVASIVE. THAN A VACCINE- AND
SO- THOSE PROFESSIONALS
HYPOTHETICAL GUIDELINES AND
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS AND THEY
HAVE TO. THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT AND THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SET. WHETHER IT'S-
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD TO THE LIKE I
DON'T KNOW THAT I CAN'T I'M NOT
CONFIDENT THIS COULD REALLY
UNDERSTANDS. OR AN EIGHTY YEAR
OLD WHO WALKS IN. I'M WANTS
SOMETHING AND SO I DON'T KNOW
THIS PERSON IS FULLY- HEARING
AND SO- IN THAT THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE TRAINED TO DO AND I'VE
COMPLETE CONFIDENCE THAT THEY'LL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT ARE HERE.
GOOD IF I COULD JUST MAKE A
COUPLE COMMENTS MR TURNER- WELL
I'M A MOM OF TWO SONS ADULT
FUNDS I'M A GRANDMOTHER OF TWO
GIRLS WHO WERE TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN. THE FIT RIGHT INTO ROB
FIT INTO THIS- AND WHAT WE HAVE
BASICALLY DURING THE CALL BUT
HAD A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THE VACCINATION WELL A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT ME BEING
VACCINATED- NOT. YOU KNOW THE
YOUNGER. ONES IN OUR IN OUR
FAMILY- AND THAT IT WAS CLEAR
THAT WE DEPENDED ON THE HEALTH
CARE EXPERTS. TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THAT DECISION AND FEEL
COMFORTABLE AND MAKING THAT
DECISION. WELL I WE HAVE A RIGHT
TO BE FULLY INFORMED WE HAVE A
RIGHT TO HAVE INFORMATION THAT
WE COULD RELY ON. I WHEN I GO TO
THE DOCTORS AND NURSES I HAVE A
RIGHT TO A SECOND OPINION ON A
THIRD OPINION I'VE A RIGHT TO
ALL OF THAT BUT FOR THE MOST
PART I'M NOT THE PROFESSIONAL I
COUNT ON THAT. BEING ABLE TO
GIVING ME THE INFORMATION THE
SCIENCE ON THE MEDICINE ALL AS
TO WELL WHATEVER DECISION I'M
I'M I'M GOING TO BE MAKING ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT HAS- REALLY
MADE ME TURN- IN IN. FRANKLY IN
IN SUPPORT WAS WHEN IT BECAME
CLEAR THAT THIS WAS. A THE RIGHT
TO TAKE A- FIX THE RIGHT BECAUSE
TO RECEIVE A VACCINE THAT HAS
BEEN FTA APPROVED. THAT IS
REALLY IN. F. APPROVED ME THE-
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE A. C. I.
P. OF THE SENATE THE FEDERAL
CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION. AND WE KNOW THAT
THESE VACCINES UNDERGO
EXTENSIVE- TRIALS THIS PROCESS
IS NOT BY PASSING. APPROVAL WE
CAN SEE ALREADY HOW LONG THE
APPROVAL PROCESS IS TAKING FOR
OUR YOUNGER. GROUPS AT ONES WERE
REALLY REALLY TAKING TIME TO A-
THERE'S- AREN'T. BACK CITY. FOR
OUR YOUNGEST- AND I APPRECIATE
THAT I APPRECIATE THAT WE- THAT
ARE. HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS.
TREAT THIS WITH- OF SUCH
SENSITIVITY AND SUCH
SERIOUSNESS- I THINK YOUNGER
PEOPLE SHOULD BE EMPOWERED TO
KNOW AS MUCH AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
ABOUT THEIR HEALTH CARE. IT
SHOULDN'T BE PARRIS JUST
STEPPING UP IN FRONT OF THEM
SAYING YOU'VE GOT TO DO THIS SO
YOU GOT TO DO THAT WE GOT TO BE
ABLE TO EXPLAIN TO THEM WHY
WOULD ALL THE REASONS GIVE THEM.
WE WANT THEM TO GROW UP TO BE
YOU KNOW FULLY INFORMED THE BILL
WHO CAN MAKE DECISIONS THAT
STARTS WHEN ONE. YOUNGER YOU
KNOW- FROM WHEN THE PANDEMIC YOU
KNOW HIT US ALL WE WERE JUST.
HOW DO WE DEAL WITH THIS HOW DO
WE AND AS THE CHAIR OF THE
LATINO **** AS WE WERE PUSHING
HARD TO MAKE SURE. THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES HAD ACCESS TO
INFORMATION HAD ACCESS TO
TESTING HAD ACCESS FINALLY TO A
VACCINATION BUT ALL THE
INFORMATION THEY NEEDED- AND
WITH THAT THEY MADE. DECISIONS
UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF THEM ARE
ARE YOU KNOW WORKING TWO THREE
JOBS IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO. TO
FOLLOW UP AS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE BUT- WHILE WE ARE- WELL
THIS IS GOING ON WE HAD TO MAKE
SURE EVERYBODY HAS ACCESS TO
THIS SO I FIGHT FOR THAT- EQUITY
I FIGHT FOR THAT INFORMATION TO
GET INTO OUR COMMUNITY. AND TO
GET INTO. OUR CHILDREN'S OUR
CHILDREN SHOULD UNDERSTAND MY
GRANDDAUGHTERS I WANTED THEM TO
UNDERSTAND THIS AND WE HAD GREAT
DEBATES BACK AND FORTH- AND THE
YOUNGER GRANDDAUGHTER SHE WAS
LIKE. I'M READY I'M READY TO GET
THIS VACCINATION SHE HELPED HER
PARENTS MAKE THE DECISION. I
MEAN I WAS JUST PROUD OF SEEING
THE WHOLE PROCESS SO. I SUSPECT
A LOT OF THIS HAS TO DO WITH THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR CHILDREN-
YOU KNOW MAKING SURE THAT WE
WERE WERE WERE TRUSTING WE TRUST
EACH OTHER. MAKE SURE WE GET ALL
THE INFORMATION WE NEED FROM
EACH OTHER THE YOUNGER ARE
YOUNGER. YOU KNOW TEENAGERS HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO TRUST US BUT IF
FOR SOME REASON THEY THEIR
LITTLE. NERVOUS ABOUT IT THEY
CAN GO TO A PROFESSIONAL AND GET. I APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT
SOGNSVANN INTO THIS AND UP BASED
ON OUR FAMILY IN OUR COMMUNITIES
EXPERIENCE- AND THE FACT THAT.
THERE WERE NINETY THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO DIE FROM SO FAR FROM
THIS PANDEMIC IN IN CALIFORNIA.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE. TEENAGERS
DIE FROM THIS- AND I WANT TO GET
TO THESE ONE MILLION OR
UNVACCINATED SO THANK YOU KNOW
BE SUPPORTING. MOVE ALREADY
HEALTH CENTER WHITE HOUSE
COMPOSABLE OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS SEEING NONE ALL RIGHT
OF. CENTER WIENER YOUR CLOTHES
ARE THANK YOU VERY MUCH BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE- FOR- THE ANALYSIS
AND THOUGHTFULNESS AND COLORS
THANK YOU FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
DISCUSSION TODAY- YOU KNOW I
JUST WANNA. A FEW THINGS THAT I
THINK SOMETIMES THIS BILL. THIS
IS A DYNAMIC FOR. BUT CUTS S. IS
. ABOUT VAXXERS PARENTS NOT
LETTING THEIR KIDS GET MAX AND
THAT IS ONE PIECE OF THIS. BUT
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THAT WE KNOW
THAT THAT MOST KIDS MANY KIDS IF
THEY WANT ABOUT ARE GOING TO
TALK TO THEIR PARENTS ABOUT THE
WE WANT KIDS TALK TO THEIR
PARENTS A LITTLE COMFORTABLE
TALKING TO THEIR PARENTS AND WE
KNOW THAT SO MANY KIDS. EVEN IF
THEY'RE THINKING ABOUT DOING
SOMETHING WE'RE GOING TO TALK TO
THEIR PARENTS NOT ALL BUT MANY.
BUT THERE ARE SOME KIDS WHO FOR
WHATEVER REASON CAN'T TALK TO
THEIR PARENTS. FOR WHATEVER
REASON THAT DYNAMIC JUST DOESN'T
EXIST AND ARE COMFORTABLE DOING
IT OR THEY DON'T FEEL SAFE DOING
IT. AND THIS WILL EMPOWER THEM
TO LOOK AFTER THEIR OWN HEALTH.
BUT THERE ARE ALSO PLENTY OF
SITUATIONS WITH MY DEMENTIA
PARENTS HAVE NO ISSUE WITH
VACCINATION BUT FOR WHAT EVER
REASON ARE NOT MAKING A TIME OR
CAN'T MAKE THE TIME. AND FOR
SOME PARENTS IDEA OF SAYING TO
YOUR KID HEY ON THE WAY HOME
FROM SCHOOL TODAY ONE TO YOU
STOP BY WALGREENS AND GET THE
FLU SHOT. THAT'S A BENEFIT TO
THOSE PARENTS I JUST MAKE SURE.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE BIG PICTURE
OF ALL THE COMPLEXITY HERE. BUT
IN THE END THIS IS ABOUT
TEENAGERS BE ABLE TO PROTECT
THEIR OWN HEALTH THIS BILL WILL
MOVE US IN THAT DIRECTION WHEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL. ALL
RIGHT AHMED CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU
WOULD CALL THE ROLL. A YES THIS
IS SENATE BILL EIGHT SIX SIX BY
SENATOR WIENER WITH THE MOTION
BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE HE THE
MOTION IS DO PASS- BURKE I. AM
BURKE HI FORTUS AREA AT ALL THE
RUSSELL DRESSED SO I'D GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I JONES. WHERE'D
LAYERED I AM A GOOD. MCGUIRE ICE
. WHITE HOUSE SKENEIDAE WHY
CASKEY I WIENER. WIENER I. THANK
HAPPEN YOU HAVE- SEVEN TWO ZERO
AT AT AND I AM LET ALONE GO
AHEAD OF THE BILLS OUT OF OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
SUBSCRIBING TODAY. JEFF OKAY YOU
HAVE. A LOT OF THINGS.
ALL RIGHT OF SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WE ARE ADJOURNED WE
WILL RECONVENE IN JUNE WITH THE
ASSEMBLY BILLS THIS IS OUR LAST
HEARING FOR THE MONTH OF MAY
WITH THE HELP ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU STAFF.